your time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's Wednesday night yep
you have your black sexual tyrannosaurus
yeah exactly my black sexual term I feel
like that is probably not the the OG
sexual Tyrannosaur hat the OG dlg sexual
tyrannosaurus hat was is tiger stripe
that's what I'm saying no I'm talking
straight well no it's not Vietnam it's
it's rothko tiger stripe which is
different from the old Vietnam pattern I
like the black one better though yeah
what's more it fits in more with this
the whole aesthetic it matches
[Laughter]
I just went to the [ __ ] club Toby
would love this one
I thought you had warrants to the club I
don't think I've ever worn this one to
the club I'm still waiting for you to
wear one of your wigs to the club that'd
be [ __ ] funny yeah you should you
keep saying you're gonna do it I know I
never but you never do it come on man
I'm bald everybody knows I'm balling
they're showing a wig what you got a wig
for them for us man it's like having fun
they're like yeah you trying to pass
yourself off as as dancing or Conan I
mean maybe you could get away with it if
there was like a theme that night where
it was like kind of a costume yeah you
could kind of like yeah I could do it
you know what I mean right because I
think they're doing like or like you
know what mannequins I think they're
doing like a a vampire ball and they're
doing like a fetish thing like yeah next
month I think I did the posters but I
can't remember when they are Zach says
Tom since you lived in Michigan did you
ever pass through uh Indy Indiana or
Indianapolis can you convey to gen just
how boring it is here
Indiana or Indianapolis is he say in
Indiana I'm assuming because that's
where the Burger Chef murders have been
in Indiana in the late 70s
well look
Sophie's from Michigan too you know she
knows that we've talked about it before
the culture up there is different man
it's uh
it's very kind of in the Box thinking
those people come out of a time when
that area was the [ __ ] center of the
[ __ ] manufacturing world it was
nothing but factories
it's because those Great Lakes made a
good place for things like you know
making foundries and then building cars
and then the things that you need to
support building cars so there's a lot
of money back there used to be that
Detroit was like the one of the richest
cities of the world it was [ __ ]
gorgeous at one time
before all that [ __ ] went to hell and
then the auto auto [ __ ] manufacturing
went to the South and Mexico okay
eventually
but you know they just don't make as
many cars as they used to
it's not all in one spot it's spread out
but what it did was is it made a it made
a culture where a guy
was supposed to really kind of be in the
Box he was supposed to grow up go to
high school get married when he got out
of high school join a union
start squeezing out kids and go to work
at the factory and then retire and then
sit around drink beer okay kind of uh Al
Bundy you know from Married with
Children like that kinda
and they sat around listening to Bob
Seger and
that was the older Generations you know
that went on for a long time they were
just like that and it made him kind of
this is kind of like the site it was
real cold Winters it was kind of like
the Siberia of America because you know
they built stuff up inside up in like
tanko grad around Siberia a lot of
factories you know
two in Russia like that and it because
they were all in a union all the time
and unionized this and that they were
kind of very structured they lived very
structured lives
uh they were always under the control of
something
they were always a part of some kind of
group
so they kind of come off the culture
almost in some way certain ways kind of
came off as to me generic generic kinda
almost kind of Russian or Soviet or
something kind of socialist in a certain
way well they seem like kind of isolated
in the sense that they didn't really
have any particular interest in other
cultures or going anywhere they kind of
just like they're all stage you could
say that the south is kind of like that
well I was going to say that I mean I
grew up in the South and the south is
kind of similar we don't have freezing
cold Winters obviously so we don't have
that
um but in some ways it is very similar
like a lot of you they're very insular
they're very conservative they don't
really like to go when he plays it's
yeah they were conservative but they
vote Democrat
real Democrat
um race I don't know if they're changing
you know but but it was yeah I think
that's changed I think that was more of
like a yeah but tradition of these
things no and I went up into the [ __ ]
80s and 90s when I was good they were
all Democrats
and uh but you see they saw Republican
party as a party of the rich Democrat
was the party of the of of the working
people and the poor people
um and it's just you know they were just
they were
the party of unions you know that's just
the way they saw it and you know they
wanted things that were
they were kind of like the Swedish I
guess you could say they're like that
kinda if you read you know they liked
very structured lives
but they were like kind of like Archie
bunkers too but they didn't yeah they
were like Archie Bunker at the same you
know if you know who that old program
this is probably making y'all make me
feel all old because even old people
that was I you know that was older
Generations knew about Archie Bunker
but there was they were kind of more
like Al Bundy from Married with Children
that they they just listened to Bob
Seger that's just but me and my buddy
Steve you know we went to high school
there part I went there part of my high
school years the other part was in
Brazil uh but Steve lived most of his
life there and and you know he's just a
[ __ ] genetic scientist and a damn
genius and he's like my brother he's
been he's been over Jenny's Maddie
he's getting so much trouble when we
were kids we didn't we were in the drama
program too he's a bass player
and we would sit around and just try to
analyze
how Michigan worked and how Michigan's
culture worked and
he never left it but he did he was
critical of it he thought it was kind of
hilarious
but there were some good parts about it
it has real good looking back especially
back in the day real good looking girls
um they were kind of bored
so if you were fun you could you could
make girlfriends really easy like me and
Steve did
um
people mostly left you alone there's a
lot of fun stuff to do you could go to
Detroit and go hang out in the goth
scene which I did it was like something
out of the crow you know that's why the
crow was set there that first movie
um
then it had nice mountains and there was
country you know you could just get lost
it's like Canada
so it did have a bunch of stuff to offer
just the people were kind of
mellow kinda
said in their ways but you know but
maybe all places are like that it's just
it's a very Factory
very old but but that's all gone now so
I don't know what they're like now yeah
I mean that was a long time ago that was
uh yeah that was 80s and 90s I mean Zach
says yeah now it's nothing but corn and
heroin use
I do kind of feel like a lot of the
Midwest and stuff like that is yeah it's
like a lot of it's mess and a lot of it
because there's nothing much to do there
there's not much to do a lot of Detroit
was returned to Nature they went and
just bulldozed whole stuff that's what
I'm saying yeah there's like nothing
there's no jobs there's not really
economically numbers
so a lot of people if that have any
prospects like get the [ __ ] out of there
yeah brain drain yeah a lot of people
left now the surrounding suburbs
evidently doing pretty well
but it's not manufacturing I don't know
what they're doing now they're not
manufacturing [ __ ]
it's just the future of America if it's
going the way it's going now is rural
and kind of suburban cities are obsolete
they're technologically obsolete
there are only big cities because of the
past
in the 1800s a city was a place where
you built things because there was one
little Factory over there and another
one over there and another one over
there and there's water running through
it you can do it well that's long gone
um you don't
things are not all located in one area
anymore it's spread out it was terrible
for the [ __ ] environment New York was
just a factory when it first started you
know just a series of factories you know
because of telecommunications you don't
need everything all in one spot anymore
uh so the future will kind of look like
suburbs in rural you won't really need
City centers in the way that they do the
only reason why they're still there is
because downtown Office Buildings the
things that [ __ ] Support Office
Buildings and then those are going
because people are working from home
online it's cheaper give the [ __ ]
price difference to the employees
instead of [ __ ] paying a big expenses
on a big ass skyscraper so they're not
going to do that though the CEO is going
to take the difference that's true
they'll just take the difference
when the [ __ ] has that ever happen
they'll knock that building down but
once those Office Buildings are gone so
those cities will vanish because
everything in that City supports those
Office Buildings
it's only a matter of time it's a
ticking Time bar
some of these groups you know Cloud
Schwab and all those guys called the
fourth Industrial Revolution having to
do with biotech and this and that and
all the old Technologies going and all
the old jobs are starting to vanish and
I used to think oh yeah [ __ ] but
then I think about it a lot of the jobs
that used to exist in the 80s and the
90s are gone
and if you look back a couple hundred
years they don't have dudes making Wagon
Wheels there were whole guys they're
whole [ __ ] few their whole purpose in
life their whole future revolved around
making barrels wooden barrels that's all
gone
so you know we just make up these jobs
as we go future jobs will be online
or and growing food building things
physical plumbers you'll always have
Tradesmen the Futures in trades
not going to colleges they're not
selling you anything you'll be able to
use really
um you wanna the money will be in
[ __ ] plumbing and construction and
[ __ ] like that
Zach says the benefit of growing up in
this dump is that gets a rag on it as
much as I want yeah yeah
uh it's not real fun there it's fun when
you're young I liked it when I was young
well it's probably fun if you drink a
lot yeah do some math but when you're
young you can make any place fun
as long as you guys are drinking a lot
yeah it's sex as long as you as long as
sex drugs and sex drugs yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah well I mean where I go I mean I
grew up in Daytona Beach Florida and
it's like there wasn't [ __ ] all to do
there either every now and then there
was like some little clubs and stuff but
not usually and I didn't have a car for
a long time so I couldn't drive over
here to Orlando or Tampa until I was a
little bit older
um you know you basically just kind of
had to sit in your room and listen to
music and drink so that's pretty much it
when you say the word Daytona to people
outside of Florida they they're picture
in Paradise
just because it's spring break yeah like
it's a constant party
it's it's kind of rural it's it's not as
rural as you think but it's not rural
it's kind of suburban it's Suburban but
I mean when I was growing up I think
it's but I haven't been back for several
years I've been there recently for VA
stuff it's nice it's nice I mean they've
done a lot to it but it's I mean it's
got like the beach and it's got but it's
real it's kind of still rednecky it's
not as rednecky as it was when I was
growing up yeah but I mean a lot of the
culture centers around uh NASCAR yeah so
it's improved a lot probably since you
were since you were young I was there
yeah there wouldn't be golf clubs there
no you're gonna have now when I was now
in the late 80s and early 90s there were
a couple tiny tiny uh there was a punk
Club but it was like a little [ __ ]
and I don't think it was the punk Club
all the time I think it was just like on
weekends and there was a little bitty
coffee house where like some punk and
Post Punk and like alternative bands
would play sometimes it was tiny tiny
tiny yeah
um but other than that yeah it was
either rednecky [ __ ] like country bars
or it was real meat market kind of [ __ ]
yeah you know what I mean people all
dressed up to get laid and fight yeah
like basic [ __ ] kind of basically it
was like that it was like that yeah
um although you could have you could
have a party there you could have a lot
of fun if you had money you could have
all your friends well I mean if you had
money then you could [ __ ] you could
do great [ __ ] that's the thing if you
have money you can do pretty much
anything you want if you don't have
money you're kind of [ __ ] they
developed it out they have [ __ ]
housing complexes like this with [ __ ]
big mansions in there looks like some
out of Miami Vice some [ __ ] it's a lot
better than it was during when she was a
little kid I was there yeah it was I was
there well I went I drove there
um God it was probably like a year or
two ago
when it was when was the last time my
sister was here I don't remember I don't
remember no it wasn't the last time it
was the time before because I drove over
there to see her and we met up at the
mall and like I was surprised at how
much they had built there I mean there's
a lot of it that's still kind of like
shitty looking but they have like tried
to improve especially kind of out
towards like the edges it's that's not
Daytona is not the main center of the
action that's something on the periphery
main actions the I-4 Corridor up where
we used to live about 20 miles up the
road 15 miles of the road going all the
way down to Orlando and then down to
Tampa and then there's not much there
and then it starts going into the
tampicos and then it goes into Saint
Pete's Clearwater and all that yeah
which is like a big metropolitan area
Tampa Clearwater St Pete they're all
like we're going eventually you're Miami
and then that's that's that's way south
of them yes Way South this is pretty big
state but anyway uh [ __ ] Florida I
saw uh two days ago
the uh the number one the top 10 number
one fastest growing cities in the United
States and four out of the ten and they
were not near the top they're they're
all cities in Florida
uh Tampa's [ __ ] getting huge
uh I mean it was huge before I lived
there back in there orange I think is
one of them is [ __ ] gross oh yeah
that's I know where that is that's
actually a bunch of my relatives live
there that's only a little bit south of
Daytona Miami's getting bigger
um
Orlando's they didn't it wasn't didn't
it's getting bigger but it didn't make
the list but almost four and then and
then two or three the other ones were
Texas so Texas and Florida are [ __ ]
getting huge
and it's people from California New York
moving here escaping [ __ ] no problems
to those places David Parker said what's
up Dave Daytona Beach where dreams die
yeah pretty much yeah I mean I found it
a very depressing place to grow up
especially for somebody
especially uh for somebody like me who
is not into outdoor [ __ ] I'm not into
beachy [ __ ] I'm not into rednecky [ __ ]
yeah so a place so being born in a place
that is kind of like all of those things
I was just kind of like God got a good
bike Racine
pretty good bikers which that was kind
of the only thing but I'm not really
into that up in that area but yeah I'm
not really into that but that was okay I
didn't mind like bike weekends up but
all that other [ __ ] like spring break
and all the races [ __ ] that God damn it
and that was like such a nightmare
living there too like all the people
that would come there because you're
talking about like half a million three
quarters of a million people like that
come for spring break or come for the uh
you know the Daytona 500 and all that
stuff and it was just a nightmare
getting anywhere because it's not a
massive town really you know so it was
like really hard to get around if you
were trying to go to work or something I
was actually born being a child in the
South my both sides of my family but I
was actually born in California and I
left in 1981.
most of Florida kind of reminds me of a
really big San Diego it reminds you of
[ __ ] Southern California in the 70s
it's kind of like that Jenny wouldn't
know she wasn't there but it's kind of
like that same Vibe I like it I like it
a lot I heard that even even to this day
San Diego area and Avista and Chula
Vista and although are still pretty cool
areas
not as good La is [ __ ] up you know
Long Beach where I've lived well LA's
been [ __ ] up for a long time yeah but
um well hell we just we just recorded a
review of that movie hardcore Yeah Yeah
from 1979 which was shot in La like in
the little CD area and it was like yeah
that was [ __ ] up back in the 70s you
know what I mean I kind of feel like a
lot of people hate La yeah and even back
then everybody hated L.A it's got a hell
of a Mystique about it because of
Hollywood and what and like oh yeah I'm
going to La that place is a [ __ ] dump
the thing about it though when I was a
kid well that's what I'm saying I was
like it's been a dump for a long time
but that's not a new phenomenon and to
be honest with you I have never like the
whole West Coast like LA and all that
kind of stuff that has never felt held
any illure for me I'm I'm more in the
east coast I like New York City uh you
know I like that kind of vibe you know I
was much more like a Velvet Underground
kind of person rather than like a glam
metal kind of person I agree you know
what I mean I'd rather live when I was
living in Massachusetts up in the Boston
area and go to New York and Boston in
between the two I'd rather live over
there than California
even though I don't really I'm not
really big into the cold weather and not
really too much into that culture
because I you know I like a lot of
outdoor stuff I like to shoot guns and
[ __ ] outdoors type [ __ ]
they don't really have that up there the
culture isn't set up for it they're kind
of puritanical in a certain way you know
they kind of descend from the Puritans
they believe things are just like this
and we're these are city folks it's too
[ __ ] Urban
see I don't mind that I don't I don't
mind that it gets I like to visit it I
don't I don't after about three or four
years of living in it you're like man
I'm [ __ ] sick of being limited by my
neighbors you know what I mean well
because like I said I mean but the thing
about it is like I said I guess because
I was born and grew up in like a real
beachy kind of area like it's not really
something that I am all that interested
in I don't mind yeah I would rather like
live somewhere where a lot of stuff was
like right there yeah you know what I
mean the thing is though is that that
isn't as alluring as it used to be
because every every place is pretty much
the same now what made California so
cool back in the 70s and what made
Boston and New York so cool as though
you could at any time go and get any
kind of food and all these nice
different kinds of exotic restaurants
[ __ ] Thai food you can get sushi you
can get [ __ ] Japanese you could get
all well every place is like that now
every place which in a way is good
because if you're if you're stuck in
some [ __ ] like out in the middle of
nowhere because at least most of the
time yeah well within reason you can
probably get some [ __ ] that you wouldn't
have been able to get back I've been all
over the [ __ ] United States just
[ __ ] traveling and going to crazy
[ __ ] with Chinese restaurants and the
best [ __ ] the best General Tso's
chicken I have was it [ __ ]
Hattiesburg Mississippi
I was like man that was some [ __ ]
good [ __ ] and you know that is better
than any Chinese food I got in Boston
which that was I didn't I didn't expect
that
it's because everybody can make anything
anywhere now you can get anything
everywhere anywhere anywhere well the
internet did that the internet did all
that you can buy any clothes anywhere it
doesn't matter where you are
because Amazon internet delivery it has
made life a lot easier when the late 90s
for people that are intellects and [ __ ]
that it's not otherwise easy back to
Mississippi in 96 or 97 around that time
and all of a sudden there was something
called online shopping and I was [ __ ]
buying golf clothes online paying for it
with a [ __ ] ATM card
and having that [ __ ] delivered to them
and I was getting close you could only
get in New York [ __ ] five ten years
before that you know what I mean you'd
have to go to [ __ ] what was the name
of that funny store that you uh uh dent
in New York New York City [ __ ] I went
there got a picture of myself standing
in front of it yeah I've been there a
lot of cool ass [ __ ] store she's like
I don't know if it's I don't know
seriously Shrine you know but you can
buy that online now so you don't have to
go to New York to buy that [ __ ] I don't
even know if that's still open anymore
everybody it's very famous I never got
rid of this call I'll probably remember
it like 15 minutes from now right or or
if DJ Maniac Is Here Yeah Mania probably
knows what it is I got a picture of
myself standing right in front of
smoking a cigarette and [ __ ] snow and
[ __ ]
yeah it's I would go there I would save
up at the zabas or something around no
it's not that's not that's a candy bar
you just had a funny name kind of had a
funny name
and they had a lot of good [ __ ] in there
they did and it was a big place well I
that's what I mean every time I went
there I would always like save up so I
could go there and get some boots and
some clothes and [ __ ] like that yeah uh
yeah somebody said John Smith said from
what I've seen I always have the
impression that Florida's a place you
going everywhere else has warrants out
for you to an extent that is probably
true that is Florida has an outlaw it
has always had an outlaw of five to it
even going back to the pirate days
well yeah we did a whole show about
Florida Pirates yep and uh people break
the law here
and there's different kinds of people
breaking the law here you have to
understand the south Florida is Central
America it still is Central America the
people from New York are moving there
trying to change it
but those people have been there for
centuries this was Spanish territory
purchased by [ __ ] uh Andrew Jackson
and uh South Florida is Central America
and you go in there and try to [ __ ] with
those people you're going to get hurt
if you watch a [ __ ] series on Netflix
called Cocaine Cowboys and you'll see
exactly they would lock a dude up give
him [ __ ] 20 years in prison and then
[ __ ] five months later they'd pull
him over for [ __ ] speed and they go
what are you doing driving a car
supposed to be in prison oh I I don't
know because they let him out because
they just have a ways you know letting
dude out the back door prison to go be
free you know totally illegal so just
because something's legal or illegal
that doesn't mean it doesn't happen it
has
that area right there is pirateville it
just still is
um as long as you're not
the cops aren't going to bother you
as long as you're not out there [ __ ]
shooting a bunch of people and doing
Street crime they'll come after you
but as long as everything is [ __ ]
copacetic you make everything look good
it seems like a
they don't really care about you
you know
uh that one guy
you got pulled over by the cops [ __ ]
he was on a date he told the cop this is
back in the [ __ ] 80s he goes look I
got a million and a half dollars in cash
in the trunk [ __ ] pound of cocaine
take it the cops just took it and he
goes have a nice night sir I need to do
and he was wanted
so it's just it's like Central America
and that's a good thing I grew up in
Brazil all right it's like it's
as long as [ __ ] everything as long as
you're not violent you're gonna be all
right all right because you start
[ __ ] around with those dudes in their
money they'll hurt you
Zach says rag on the west coast all you
want but the Pacific Northwest is
gorgeous yeah it I've never been there
but um yeah what I mostly say was it's
not so much like because I know like
Northern California is like gorgeous for
the mountains and stuff it's supposed to
like La I'm talking about
um my sister lived in Seattle for quite
a while and she uh quite liked it there
but yeah I've always thought like
Washington State and stuff like that
like looked really gorgeous up there let
me put it this way and I like that it
rains all the time I'm into that Miami
is like a very big higher class
South American or Central American
version of New Orleans
all right I lived in New Orleans too or
the New Orleans area area past Christian
Mississippi is just [ __ ] 30 minutes
to it
uh there's a Sylvester Stallone movie
called Bullet to the Head you go watch
that that's actually kind of [ __ ]
accurate it also has been some stuff
like what was that True Detective they
talk about [ __ ] that happens in that
area it's got a strong it has always had
a strong kind of mob
culture to it going back to the pirate
days and stuff uh but guys from New York
moved into into New Orleans way back in
the 50s
and they kind of took over and that
became part of the culture and now
they're kind of like Southern versions
of mobsters they're out there and the
cops are totally corrupt and
it's a rough place you know but it's
small it's and it's it's Southern it's
weird
I don't recommend New Orleans some
people go to the French Quarter and have
a good time but I recommend it
it it's it's it's dangerous and if you
go for this the safer versions of going
down to the to New Orleans then you're
not really seeing it the true New
Orleans
the true New Orleans you're going to end
up in a prison a hospital or a cemetery
that's what's going to happen to you
yeah they had some of the rust roughest
[ __ ] projects you could ever imagine
down there
all right let's go you ready to do the
show
uh yeah so we have the base of let's
hear about the yoga shop we're actually
going to do the Burger Chef murders
first because that happened earlier what
happened with this was that
we did a show uh not too long ago but we
had a show called fast food massacres
and I think we talked about like five or
six but I had like a whole bunch of
other cases on there that I had wanted
to talk about and we didn't have time to
get to them because the show like ran
really long as usually happens so there
was a bunch of cases that I didn't get
to and I specifically wanted to get to
these two cases the Burger Chef murders
and the Austin yogurt shop murders
because I had uh read and written a lot
about them before and so I was kind of
sad and somebody said well why don't you
just like do that as a whole show like
on its own so I was kind of like okay
let's do that and finally it got uh the
most votes in the patreon poll so I was
like woohoo finally and I've I thought
this was probably a good time to do it
because I feel like in July we haven't
done any True Crime yeah we've done uh
we did a pirate show we did a show about
Lewis Carroll we did a show about uh the
British premonition uh Bureau but we
haven't done any True Crime for a while
and you know you guys know True Crime is
kind of my thing I mean I like
I like the Paranormal stuff too
um and I especially like like weird
history [ __ ] also but I mean True Crime
is always kind of gonna be my favorite
thing to do is kind of depressing as it
is but you know I like Paranormal
that's what well I know but like I said
all month we've been doing not
necessarily paranormal but we've done
like stuff that wasn't true crime yeah
you know what I mean so I kind of feel
like it was so good it was good that we
got back to that Isabella says it looks
like they put a name to the Somerton man
holy [ __ ] I need to like look that up no
[ __ ] really God damn that's been since
what 1948 that was right they found his
body oh man I'm so that case is like so
fascinating yeah I even I made a shirt
that says like who is Summerton man with
all the like [ __ ] they found around his
body and stuff but um holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to look that up after the
show if I remember
but you know that's crazy
I kind of hope you know if they could
solve that and is doll woman that would
I could die happy and find out who the
Zodiac was
if they solve those three
I don't know if it you know it's it's
not gonna change anything in my life or
anything but it's just like those three
cases for whatever reason I'm just kind
of like really curious about what the
[ __ ] happened there you know what I'm
saying but yeah I'm gonna have to look
that up I hadn't heard about that but
like I said I've been kind of like busy
today so I haven't seen it but yeah
that's pretty cool
so yeah so okay so the first thing we're
going to talk about is the Burger Chef
murders now these happened in 1978. now
I'm not entirely sure now Burger Chef
used to be I kind of remember like
hearing about it I don't know if we had
any of them in Florida like I don't
remember if I've ever seen one it looks
kind of familiar the sign but I don't
know if that's just because I've seen
pictures of it like in later years
apparently they used to be back in the
old days they were kind of like a big
competitor to McDonald's in certain
parts of the country but I don't think I
think maybe the last one closed in the
90s although I could be wrong about that
I don't remember ever seeing one in real
life though
uh yeah Seth says yeah they solve
Summerton man who's a professor at the
Adelaide University that oh it was a
professor professor at Adelaide
University that solved it he wasn't a
spy unfortunately ah [ __ ] well that's
kind of disappointing I mean you know
I'll look it up later what to make me
wait oh maybe we should do like a whole
special like update show on like summer
to man if they actually figured out it
turns any witnessed by
I missed it that's a bummer oh [ __ ] yeah
who was you well I don't know I guess
I'm gonna find out
Camp guy said their mascots were Burger
Chef and Jeff Jeff was a little kid in
their TV ads
Isabella said it was only yesterday they
released the info of course the Black
Dahlia might still be solvable yeah I'm
kind of hoping they use like a lot of
DNA info to like figure out all these
yeah because I would actually love to
have the Black Dahlia case off too now
that we're talking about it I have never
been to a Burger Chef I don't think I've
ever seen it that's what I'm saying I
think
they all closed in the 90s and I'm not
really sure I don't know if we have them
in Florida I mean maybe we did here's
the thing it's like remember the other
day when we were talking about like fast
food things that I wish was down here
and some and everybody talks about
Culvers and how like amazing it is with
their Frozen Custard and I didn't even
know that we actually have three Culvers
like within 20 miles of here I was like
who the [ __ ] knew I didn't I thought
that was just like a Midwestern thing
um so show us how much I know so I mean
we don't eat fast food all that much no
um you know so it's not worth it here
well and the thing is there's not one
there's not really that many around here
and two the only time we would ever stop
is if we were going someplace like or
drunk or coming back from the club or
something like that and it's usually
McDonald's or someplace that's on the
way and there's not really a lot that's
on the way there's so many good mom pod
type restaurants around here like the
[ __ ] trough and and Indian
restaurants and sushi restaurants yeah I
mean if we eat out we usually eat at the
Japanese place or we go or we drive a
little bit farther to Lake Mary and go
to the Indian place or something like
that like you know and like I said if we
eat fast food it's usually McDonald's
because that's what's on the route
that's like pretty much the only one
that's on the route so Burger Chef I'm
not really sure like I said I think in
some parts of the country maybe I'm
thinking maybe the 50s and 60s they were
like a competitor with McDonald's at
least in certain parts of this I've seen
nations of the Interior yeah but they
served it to me it looked kind of like
Big Boy kind of like a Proto prototype
yeah I don't remember if we ever had any
big boys either did we if I was big boy
I used to work at one but back before I
went to the Army I thought we had one in
Florida because I could have sworn that
I saw that big fiberglass Big Boy
setting up on the Lakes but maybe I'm
just like I don't know maybe I'm hungry
in high school [ __ ] um grandpar's
probably remembers that
I think it was my sophomore uh no Junior
no sophomore or Junior year I don't
remember I worked as a part-time as a
waiter in there
at Big Boy cross street
made all kinds of tips now I knew we had
a I know we had a Showboat because I
remember my uncle yeah either managing
one of those or I think he managed one
like back in the 70s
who's you guys have in your channel
always something interesting thank you
thank you well I think it's because
between well between the two of us we
have like a very very broad range of
interests we've got some overlap but we
also got a [ __ ] ton of Divergence yeah
so we can come up with some [ __ ] so I
think that's good and honestly like both
of us are really interested in a lot of
different things so I kind of feel like
that's one of the things that we wanted
when we first started the channel
in a way that might be to our detriment
because I feel like sometimes channels
that are more focused like do better
yeah
um because everybody's like oh if you
want to hear about XYZ you go to this
place but ours is just kind of like all
over the place but we kind of conceived
it like that from the beginning because
I said well I don't want to be limited
because what if I want to do a show
about this and it's like that's like oh
that doesn't really fit in and it's like
I don't want to get into that kind of
situation yeah I do I can't be boxed in
in that fashion the idea for the show
was a personality driven kind of like
fun show that did a variety of
mysterious topics but then we had good
regulars that we talked to and it was
for a smaller crowd not really a big
crowd just a smaller more dedicated
crowd and [ __ ] we've been around [ __ ]
six years now huh
uh yeah five or six years yeah actually
yeah when did we start we started in the
summer of 2016. we didn't really make a
living at it but it supplements yeah so
it'll be almost six years almost six
years yeah yeah we're coming up on like
six years we've been doing it it's
ridiculous it is ridiculous yeah and
look how like how much we've expanded
out like with all the movie reviews and
honestly
I just started the new horror Channel
and August 1st I think it's gonna go up
August 1st I'm waiting to see I'm like
I'm pretty much I have most of the stuff
that I wanted to put up up
um I'm starting another Channel
on August 1st I think it's gonna go live
another website and another Channel and
that's going to be all True Crime so I'm
gonna have an ultra crime one and I'm
gonna have all horror one and then we're
still gonna have this one yeah because I
don't have because I I you know I don't
have enough work to do I have to make
more work for myself it's just it's the
way I roll that's how I roll I can't
help it
I feel like I feel like lazy if I'm not
doing 40 things at once
it's an issue uh but yeah John Smith
says I miss Wimpy's a fast food chain
for my childhood I remember there being
a Wimpy's uh
the first time I went to the UK in the
mid 90s there was a wimpies right by the
Cardiff train station because I remember
eating there a couple of times
but I didn't know that that was gone now
because I haven't been to the UK
probably since 2009 or so but I remember
eating at the wimpies there like for
because that was like a big uh chain
over there yeah it's kind of like it's
kind of like McDonald's or Burger King
or something like that it was very
similar
um let's see Tom should dress up like
Robert Stack from unsolved mystery oh
[ __ ] if you could do the voice that
would be like super cool I'd have to get
high
well you know go for it now his voice
man is yeah I can't do that I mean
that's iconic that's iconic you got to
be born with a voice like that you do
uh Zach says first vid of yours I
watched was the Golden State killer
update because I was watching a ton of
stuff about it back in 2018 yeah that's
right because we did the show about
Golden State killer before they caught
him yeah and then like after they caught
him after that's that D'Angelo [ __ ]
yeah then we did like an update I
predicted his ass
pretty much I think we could I haven't
gone back and listened to that show but
a lot of people like have messaged me
and said yeah you called a lot of them
yeah I called you I had a feeling of
what who that what kind of guy that was
because I I knew he was I knew he was
either military or police probably
police
yeah well turned out he was both when he
was I think he was a little bit I think
it was both yeah
he was comfortable doing what he was
doing it's military police yeah yeah
that's I mean crazy so we got distracted
by the whole [ __ ] had that
little dick head little dick syndrome
big time yeah big time but yeah so we
got distracted by the whole Burger Chef
issue so I don't know if you still have
a Burger Chef where you are let me know
but I'm pretty sure they all closed in
the 90s but I could be wrong about that
yeah I'm curious I'm curious to know if
they were any good
I mean I imagine they were probably like
the same qualities Burger King at the
time I mean this is the 70s we're
talking the late 70s that we're talking
about when this is it was good I
remember it
yeah but was it was it just good in the
context of the time or if you ate it
nowadays would it still be good like I
remember getting pizza back in the 70s
it was [ __ ] fantastic
Round Table
see I always kind of wonder about that
because yeah we had a good local place
yeah that pizza place that was good but
I kind of wonder if I ate there nowadays
would it be anything special it was real
Buffalo mozzarella
[ __ ] would stretch out like that and
[ __ ] cheese that high on it that [ __ ]
was good man down in California yeah it
I remember Pizza Hut was good back in
the 70s did it was a sit down well it
was a sit down yeah I used to I mean I
don't even remember if the pizza one is
they didn't get it I was just used to
like to go sit down and like play with
the Jukebox and stuff yeah you know what
I mean and get those big [ __ ] things
of Mountain Dew uh Seth says first
episode I watched was about Houdini I
love that one that was honestly one of
my favorite early episodes I don't think
it got as many views as some of the
other ones because who the hell cares
about like Houdini like fighting the
spiritualist and all that sounds but I
love that kind of stuff yeah I love that
kind of stuff next to mention media said
first show I listened to of yours was
Logan's Run review you guys did a great
job in tuning in ever since yeah next
Dimension the shirts got got delayed a
little bit we got to wait on yeah we got
the wrong kind of ink yeah so I had to
order I got acrylic ink instead of
fabric ink right so I had to order
another thing yeah shop the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] came out discolored and I was like
what the hell's wrong with this I tried
to cook it it boiled because you cooked
it with a heat gun I said I'm gonna wash
it when it came back a lot of it came
out and I looked at the can and it
wasn't it's not she got the she got the
wrong side by accident I mean I don't
blame her it looks exactly the same yeah
the jar looks exactly the same there was
like a tiny little one little icon icon
on there that was different and I was
just kind of like oh really thanks a lot
it's for doing wood
wood and poster art and stuff
so uh that's the same for you
um
yeah I'm waiting I did that ocp shirt
came out great but it's the wrong kind
of ink
so I we lost five [ __ ] shirts gotta
throw them away
head replacement so I lost my ass on
that people
could have sent that [ __ ] it had been
[ __ ] up though yeah I was like yeah
the images would have come off over time
it's not that big a deal I mean the
shirts aren't horribly expensive it's
like I ordered them from Jiffy shirts
all the time and they're really fast so
you know yeah I was more pissed about
the ink because I paid a lot for that
ink yeah it was like a 30 jar and I'm
like got a big one oh yeah I got it and
then it just and then it wasn't it
wasn't the right kind so then I had to
go and then I went back to Amazon and
they didn't have any fabric ink that was
white so I had to go to Blick and get
ink from them so I had just got a
smaller one because I'm like look I
can't [ __ ] afford this so the one
they had was like only 10 bucks but then
the shipping was like another 10 bucks
so you know what I mean all right let's
get that let's get down to this [ __ ]
case I mean [ __ ] man [ __ ] oh are you
yelling at me about it no it's just it's
just a situation Not the Only You
Gotta you're the one that's like been
talking about random [ __ ] the whole time
hey you know I've been drinking we gotta
get down that's always your excuse all
right so the Burger Chef murders those
are the one we're gonna talk about first
like I said we'll do the Austin yogurt
yogurt shot murders like second
but this was something that happened in
1978 uh in November uh in Speedway
Indiana where actually that's where the
speedway is like where they do the Indy
500 uh I didn't I don't know if a lot of
people know that there's actually a town
there but yeah uh Speedway Indiana so
that's where this happened now initially
here's the kind of shitty thing about
this case it's
it's still like kind of Unsolved I kind
of feel like they probably know who
probably did it but the people who did
it allegedly are dead so there's not
really any way of closing the case the
shitty thing too about this one was that
the police really dropped the ball on
this one uh they really didn't take it
seriously at first because they thought
it was something else or it wasn't
really that big of a deal and then like
later on when it turned out it was a
quadruple homicide
um by the time that happened like a lot
of the evidence was gone and so they
didn't really have much chance of
solving it and you know later on like
some cops didn't come forward yeah we
[ __ ] that I'm like yeah you did [ __ ]
that up you did [ __ ] that up but uh you
know we'll get into that
so November 17th 1978 and it's a little
after midnight and there's a guy named
Brian
and he's driving back to his house
uh which then as I mentioned Speedway
Indiana
now he worked at the Burger Chef but he
wasn't working that night but he did
work there
so he's like you know what I'm I'm going
by the Burger Chef I'm gonna stop by and
see my friends that work there
um and because it was you know a little
bit past closing time so he's like maybe
they need some help closing up or
whatever and I could just stop and say
hi to them
so when he gets to the Burger Chef he
goes in and the restaurant is empty like
there's nobody there it's past closing
time like I said it was probably about
an hour past closing time at this point
I think it closed at 11 o'clock
uh it wasn't locked though the place
wasn't locked but nobody was in there
now that night there were four employees
that were supposed to be working their
shifts uh Jane Freight Freight or fright
fright I'm not sure it's f-r-i-e-d-t oh
it's raining yeah it's coming down okay
hopefully the power doesn't go out yeah
we have the power click out yeah shuts
down it's the storm it's not us people
yeah I mean it just says rain off and on
right here but well the power went out
yesterday just for a second and I guess
when he was trying to reset my digital
clock he accidentally set my alarm yeah
so my alarm went off at six a.m and like
woke me up and I was just kind of like
God damn it I mean it's not really that
it's that's not much earlier than I
would get up anyway so it wasn't that
big a deal but I'm just saying I was
just kind of like why the [ __ ] is my
alarm going off I never said that [ __ ]
but yeah
so uh so Jane who she was 20 years old
and she was I think the manager and
there was another kid a 16 year old
named Daniel Davis and then another 16
year old named Mark flemons and a 17
year old named Ruth Shelton now they
were the ones that were all supposed to
be working the closing shift that night
so uh as I mentioned he went in and they
were all gone now the door was open and
the lights were all still on uh the safe
which was in the office was open and
there was nothing in it later on they
would determine that 581 dollars in 1978
dollars had been stolen out of it which
is about 24 2500 in today's money
um so it so everything was gone to the
safe now interestingly though and this
is kind of like why they thought
initially and why they still think
nowadays why it wasn't maybe totally a
robbery was because even though there
was money gone from the safe uh both
Jane's and Ruth's purses were still
there and didn't look like they'd been
rifled through or anything like that and
there was also money left in the
register which is about a hundred
dollars in 1978 money they didn't think
the girls had any money they didn't
bother maybe not or like I said they
didn't go in the register either I don't
know they were just totally focused on
the safe maybe but like I said we'll get
into maybe there was some other
motivations so we'll get into that we'll
see
um Jane's car was also missing from the
parking lot
so at this point Brian who like I said
was an employee at the restaurant but
wasn't working that night so he calls
around to see if he can find Jane who is
the manager on shift that night
and he calls another uh you know he's
trying to like find her he calls her
house she doesn't answer he calls like
some of the other people that we're
supposed to be working they don't answer
either
um he calls another Burger Chef
Restaurant where Jane used to work and
they're like we don't know where the
[ __ ] she is either so he starts getting
worried about it
so he calls the head manager
um of the of the Burger Chef in Speedway
and he says hey I walked into the [ __ ]
like you know and nobody's in there and
like the safe was open like nothing
looks Disturbed but it wasn't locked or
anything
so the manager's like well okay that's
pretty weird call the cops
so the speedway police show up
their initial assessment of the scene
though was that
um okay so they come in and they're like
yeah the back door is unlocked uh you
know there are purses Left Behind one of
the cars is gone but their whole Theory
from the start of this was that the four
employees had decided that they were
going to open the safe take all the
money and go out on the town partying
like they were gonna go out and drink
and you know that's why they were all
gone
so the cops were just kind of like ah
they'll come back later it's fine they
just took the money and went out to
party and then we'll catch them when
they come back from wherever they went
off to
so you know
uh the manager was just kind of like
um I actually know these people and
that's really not something they would
do but okay you guys are the cops so
presumably you know better
um so the cops were like oh it's fine
you can totally open this restaurant the
next day so the morning shift came in
and cleaned the whole place top to
bottom getting rid of all physical
evidence whatever physical evidence
might have been left behind
so
not good not good
uh they didn't even take any pictures of
the inside or nothing they did nothing
because their whole assumption was these
are four people that just took off with
the money and that's pretty much it
now obviously because we're talking
about this on this show uh that wasn't
what happened
so none of the people showed up uh at
home obviously or for their next you
know shift at the Burger Chef so their
families were kind of like okay we're
pretty sure that they didn't just run
off with the money and go like drinking
at a bar or just to a strip club or
something
and then like the next day
uh November 18th
uh Jane's car which was a 1974 white
Chevy Vega was found abandoned and still
locked like in a lot in the middle of
town
so at this point they're like okay maybe
something more Sinister is going on and
that maybe these four people had
actually been abducted from the
restaurant
thanks cops it's about time you came to
that [ __ ] conclusion
the next morning which was a Sunday
November 19th
uh the cops get a call from this place
it was kind of like a rural area which
is about 20 miles uh from the town of
Speedway about 20 miles from where the
restaurant was
two people had been walking around their
property and had found four dead bodies
lying face down in the dirt
uh so these were obviously the four
employees of the Burger Chef they still
had the Burger Chef Uniforms on and
everything
Ruth and Daniel
uh had been uh just basically shot in
the head execution style 38 caliber
little ways away they found Jane now she
was actually found with um now some
Reports say that she had like a it was
like a five inch like hunting knife
blade like sticking out of her sternum
some say they didn't find the blade
until later when they did the autopsy
and then like they found it like inside
of her because the handle of the knife
had broken off okay
um so I don't know which of those is
true I've heard both uh you know
could depending on like the source
now a little way away from that like
down at the bottom of a hill they found
Mark and he had been beaten to death
uh with something that maybe was a chain
that looked like a chain uh and it
actually like asphyxiated on his own uh
blood
now that's a weird way to go yeah it is
not a good weapon well and it's strange
too that they hadn't just all been shot
I mean you know because it's like two of
them were just shot execution style but
the other two what you resist again 78.
yeah chain that's like out of the damn
biker movie 60s and 70s bikers 60s
bikers movies I mean it seemed like they
wanted to make that person suffer yeah
but it's just not a good weapon it's not
solid you can't [ __ ] actually get
much energy onto a dead person's head
with that well I guess it worked in this
oh they don't know bar is better they
don't know 100 that it was a chain but
they're sure it was something like a
chain a chain or something like I wonder
I'd like to see the evidence that made
them think that okay go ahead
so the cops get there obviously uh their
initial assessment of the scene was
drastically drastically erroneous
but they didn't really do uh that much
of a better job when they actually like
found the bodies
um all kind of like [ __ ] just they had
people like coming over the crime scene
they like took some [ __ ] from the crime
scene without realizing it's just like
you know what I mean it was just like a
[ __ ] show
uh so now what they assume now this
isn't completely stupid because they
think this is probably you know they
thought this is probably what happened
they said well obviously this was a
robbery gone wrong like you know they
they somebody came in to rob the place
and maybe these people fought back or
maybe there was something else going on
and like they took them I mean the fact
that they would take them 20 miles
that seems a little bit more than just a
robbery gone wrong you'd think that if
it was a robbery gone wrong they would
have just shot them at the site
but yeah I don't really know
now the sad thing about this I mean
other than everything about it which is
sad but Mark one of the victims wasn't
actually supposed to be working that
night
um he had like filled in for somebody
else
so because he wasn't supposed to be
there and they thought that maybe this
was a robbery they said okay well maybe
what happened was that the robbers had
planned this but they didn't plan for
that specific guy to be there and maybe
that specific guy recognized them and so
the robbers were like okay well we have
to kill all of them because of witnesses
because they know who we are so that's
kind of like the theory that they were
going on
as I said um all of them still have
their Burger Chef Uniforms on uh they
had not been robbed a lot of them have
still had jewelry watches like cash in
their pockets all kind of stuff uh so
obviously it wasn't you know even though
the robbers or who whatever the
murderers had taken money from the safe
they didn't take anything off of the
people which is interesting
so uh yeah
now what ends up happening with this so
the cops are like okay well now they're
looking for information about anybody
that might have seen anything because
otherwise they didn't have [ __ ] all to
go on
so on the same day that the bodies were
found after they kind of put out a call
for information uh this teenage boy
calls the cops and he says you know I
saw these two kind of suspicious looking
dudes hanging around the Burger Chef
Restaurant like before it closed like on
the night that the murders happened
now according to this guy uh the people
he saw it was two guys they were both
white guys probably about in their 30s
and he said that these two guys had come
up to him and his girlfriend they said
they were sitting in the parking lot of
the Dunkin Donuts which was next to the
Burger Chef
and told them that it's like uh this is
the quote well he said you have to get
out of here because they're a quote
there has been lots of vandalism going
on like so they told him and his
girlfriend to leave like they were
sitting in their car
so this kid tells the cops he's like
okay one of the dudes had a beard uh the
other one was clean shaven and had
blonde hair he said the guy with the
beard was the one that did all the
talking but he held up like a
handkerchief in front of his mouth like
while he was talking almost like he
didn't want to be recognized or he
wanted to try and cover his face or
something like that
so they did some composite sketches uh
from the descriptions and then for some
reason they don't because normally they
wouldn't you usually do this
but they got like some forensic artist
to do like life-size clay sculptures of
the P of the suspects they had some
money to pass around didn't they I get
like why would they do that that seems
like very strange and if you've ever
seen like a few good 70s if you Google
it those uh clay busts are
really freaky looking yeah like just let
you know what I mean are they accurate
or they're not accurate are they just
funny well I don't know because they
didn't catch the people but it's just
kind of like they're I don't know
they're weird looking okay they're weird
looking it just seems like a strange
thing I was like look drawing it would
be so much cheaper like why would you go
to the time and expense they they just
knew somebody that could do it that's
what I'm thinking it's like well we have
the clay person and they're just kind of
like I'll do I'll I'll make a
three-dimensional that'd be so much
better than like a drawing 400 bucks
it'll take I kind of yeah I feel like
you know my cousin does like yeah he
could probably yeah I kind of feel like
it does some some nepotism situation
because otherwise much easier and
quicker just to like draw it with
charcoal or a pencil or something like
that why get it all the time because
that takes a really long time that's
what they did like sculpting something
out of it well there's politics too
that's what I'm saying they're showing
the public look at all the effort we're
putting into this [ __ ] hey boss I did
good didn't I you know that that's what
it is even though they're totally weird
looking yeah I think they're totally
weird looking I haven't seen them judge
I mean well like I said like three
stacks from Land of the Lost I don't
know they just I don't know it's it's a
little bit it's hard to explain they
look a little bit uncanny valley but
they also look a little bit I don't know
they're just kind of like misshapen I
don't know there is like really really
scary yeah okay
uh DJ Maniac says uh First Night Shift
has me sleep until 6 PM hence why I've
been around lately if that's okay maybe
you gotta do what you got to do now that
you're here I want to ask you the
question what was the name of that
clothing what was the name of that
underground or goth clothing uh [ __ ]
store down in New York New York City
what is it called Riff Raff no it's not
a no that's the guy from Rocky Horror
Picture yeah I was there I took a
picture of it I was too I just don't
remember right now because I wasn't
thinking about it so it's like it's not
it's in a locked filing cabinet in my
brain
but yeah so clay busts I I don't know
weird
so
so what ends up happening after this
um the clay bus like I said they do look
like they could resemble an actual human
being they're just I don't know they're
kind of uncanny valley like I said
there's a little bit weird looking
now uh oh okay what are you doing okay
worry about what I'm doing
trying to micromanage I'm not
micromanaging I'm just wondering what
the [ __ ] you're doing because I don't
know if I'm gonna get like interrupted
or something trash in Vaudeville that's
it Jimmy used to run it till he passed
years ago is it still open because I
mean it's been years since I've been
there but I've been there lots of times
okay so one of the clay bus I guess
looked enough like a person that uh
somebody that looked like one of the
sketches or like one of the clay busts
somebody overheard him in a bar like
near where the murders happen
uh talking about committing the murders
like basically being in a bar as one
does being like yeah I killed those
people probably like playing pool or
whatever talking about how they killed
somebody not the not the smartest uh you
know Criminal
trash and Vaudeville that's right yeah
that's right they did Punk and gossip
yeah yeah trash involved religious sex
yeah on St Marks I remember that one too
uh yeah DJ Maniac said Jimmy opened the
same guy that did trash and Vaudeville
open a new store around the block a few
months later different name though okay
that's the got the blonde hair right
long curly blonde hair skinny guy
he's probably got to be [ __ ] his 70s
now 60s 70s
no he's dead he's dead now he said Jimmy
used to run it till he passed a year oh
you're okay a year what did he die from
[ __ ] I remember that guy kind of like a
little skinny he was cool looking he was
cool talk to him [ __ ] bought some
[ __ ] from him he was selling a lot of
shrine back then
yeah I remember that being there yeah
because it was right 90 excuse me no
that was [ __ ] 2000
10 that I was there I think
yeah around 2010 2009 so we're on that
time
okay so one of the people
that kind of look like one of the
sketches or the clay figures the clay
things
was in a bar talking about like bragging
about the murder
so somebody obviously calls the police
it is like hey there's some jackass in
here like talking about it you did the
murders
so uh so the cops like sent an
undercover agent into this bar
and he goes over there and starts
playing pool with the dude and [ __ ] like
that
and the dude apparently like no shame
he's just sitting there bragging about
yeah I [ __ ] I robbed the people and
killed him and it's like yeah I'm the
man like that kind of [ __ ] what he said
Jimmy wasn't exactly young he said dude
sold to Iggy and Prince and there's a
laundry list yeah he was old [ __ ] in
2010 I thought he was in his 60s but he
looked good I mean for his age he was
skinny
uh in good pretty good shape long blonde
hair kind of curly kind of frizzy he'd
look like a higgy Iggy Pop kinda you
know like a blonde Dicky pop they're
funny that you say that
but uh he was cool I liked the guy wait
oh may I you can go
I'm done
all right
so obviously uh the cops are kind of
like well since it's an undercover cop
and this guy is like saying yeah Rob the
people and it's like look I [ __ ] I
busted them all up like breaking a pool
cue and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so the cops arrested him and bring him
in for you know interrogation but once
they bring him into the police station
he's like man I don't have anything to
do with that I was just like [ __ ] I
was just talking uh they gave him a
polygraph test and he supposedly passed
it although I think back in the 1970s uh
I feel like the polygraph test was maybe
more
looked at with more Authority than like
nowadays like now you pass a polygraph
test everyone's like big deal like a lot
of people can pass polygraph tests and
they're so guilty but because he passed
it they were kind of like oh guess it
wasn't you
so they let him go
um but while he was there he's like oh
but I didn't do it but I do know like
all these people that are involved in
like this robbery gang that go around
like sticking up a bunch of like fast
food places
so going on these leads the cops
eventually locate this dude who looked
like the bearded guy that the teenager
talked about now he lived in a town
nearby uh I don't think he's ever been
named not that I could ever find anyway
um so he looked a lot like uh you know
the drawing and the and the clay
sculpture kind of and he didn't actually
have uh an alibi for the night that the
murders occurred
and a guy that he knew who I think lived
next door to him
had blonde hair and looked just like the
other guy that they had made like the
clay statue of
so the cops are kind of like to the
bearded man they're like hey why don't
you come in for like a lineup and we'll
see if some of the witnesses can
identify you like the 16 year old
witness he shows up for the lineup and
he shaved his beard off
which seems a little suspicious I mean
you can't like convict somebody on that
but again it seems a little suspicious
um so the cops are just kind of like
look if you guys will tell us what you
know like we'll give you a plea deal but
neither one of them would talk and they
didn't have any hard evidence because
like I said when they first investigated
the crime they had you know the
restaurant got cleaned they didn't have
any physical evidence so they basically
just had to let him go
now so that was kind of one line of
inquiry they were pursuing this other
line of inquiry
um was that and I think this same kind
of thing would come up in the Austin
yogurt shop murders if I'm not mistaken
although I don't think there was
anything to it
but they were talking about they're like
oh well maybe out of this particular
Burger Chef
um one or more of the employees of this
restaurant might have been dealing drugs
or knew somebody that was dealing drugs
maybe it was like some kind of drug kind
of thing
because what ended up happening was that
Jane
who had been like the assistant manager
who was working that night her brother
uh whose name was James was later
arrested on cocaine charges like a
couple of years after the murders
so for a while cops were like oh well
maybe he was dealing drugs back then at
the time and like you know the robbers
are kind of like threatening her like
because of something he did or some [ __ ]
like that
so uh so they brought him in for
questioning but they couldn't really
find anything about that either but they
did find out like maybe there was
something to this particular angle
because what happened six years after
the murder occurred this was in November
of 1984.
uh the cops in Speedway get a phone call
from this dude named Donald Wayne
Forrester now he was calling from a
prison the Pendleton Correctional
Facility and he was uh he had just been
put in prison for 95 years for rape now
he was 35 years old
and he basically says to the cops I'm
the one that did the Burger Chef murders
he wanted to confess to it
now the cops were kind of like yeah sure
you did because the thing about it was
that they knew that this dude Forester
he was going to be moved from he was in
a state person in Indiana and he was
going to be moved to another prison
called Michigan City
and because he was a sex offender they
said yeah
um the the prisoners at Michigan City
are like well known for not being like
super understanding about people that
what hold on one second I want to show
uh I want to show my boy that was me
that was me outside trash in Vaudeville
man I look like a baby and it was only
10 years ago
Jesus Christ okay good
you look like our friend Matt yeah look
at Matt and I look like I look like a
little swell
yeah
okay where was I I got pictures of me in
Central Park doing a photo shoot
me doing a photo shoot in Central Park
hold on
notice those [ __ ] Bridges
didn't do okay
Central Park
okay you sure that's it you sure I'm
giving it to my show my boy
you sure you're done show my voice
I gotta check okay can I please get on
that's what I was talking about
beautiful ass photographs I realized
that [ __ ] like a goddamn I remember
that photo shoot I got some [ __ ]
pictures of Jenny that are so [ __ ]
cute okay go ahead good may I you're not
going to interrupt me again are you
going to interrupt you are you sure yeah
okay because I lost my face before
I know we have to make everything all
about you but yeah
all right
so this guy Forrester they figure okay
we don't know if he actually has any
actual information because it could be
that he's just afraid that he's going to
get moved to this other prison where his
sex offender ass is gonna get like beat
the [ __ ] up or killed
um so he's like gonna parlay some
information that he has like into maybe
like a better deal like maybe he can
move somewhere else or not get moved
um now he did actually want to do that
but when they started interviewing him
they were kind of like maybe there's
something to this because he did seem to
have some
information that uh was not widely
disseminated at the time let's put it
like that
um they did discover that at the time of
the murders in November of 1978
Forrester was actually living in
Speedway Indiana
uh and that he had also when he was a
kid he had grown up in the area where
the bodies were discovered which was 20
miles away so you know again suspicious
um so they bring him in and he's like
yeah I'm the guy that killed uh Daniel
and Ruth like the ones that were shot
they were like executed with the 38.
so they drive him to the field where the
bodies were found
and he without prompting apparently was
able to tell them where each of the
bodies was and like how the bodies were
positioned uh which wasn't common
knowledge so again that's uh you know
that's pretty damning right there
and basically he's kind of like he's
like what happened he's like after we
did the murders because I think he said
that it wasn't just him
because like after we did the murders we
drove out to where the field like where
we killed the the people and we picked
up the shell casings
he's like once we found him
I drove back home and I flushed him down
the toilet of like the house that I used
to live in
now they asked forrester's ex-wife about
this and she backed up the story
apparently without any prompting from
him
so the cops get a search warrant like
obviously there was other people like
living in this house now but they got
like a um like a search warrant to
search through the septic tank
police work y'all it's super fun so they
had to like dig through the septic tank
and in the septic tank they did indeed
find a bunch of uh shell casings from a
38. so that checked out
now what Forrester said happened on that
particular night
he said that Jane's Jane the assistant
manager like one of the victims that her
brother James who like I said was a
couple years later was uh arrested for a
cocaine uh possession
he was allegedly
um in deep with some drug dealers like
he owed them some money and he had like
[ __ ] them over
so on this particular night uh Forester
and a bunch of other dealers like drug
dealers go to the Burger Chef and
they're gonna [ __ ] with Jane like to try
to get James to like to pay up is what
they were doing
so they show up and they start
threatening to [ __ ] her up if her if her
brother doesn't like cough up the money
and then
16 year old Mark who was another kid
that was working at the restaurant he
jumps in and like tries to defend her
like hey like leave her alone like don't
hurt her and then at that point like a
big fight started
during this fight allegedly Forrester
said that Mark actually fell and hit his
head not sure I believe that but okay
um they said that he was knocked
unconscious when he fell and because the
guys that were there thought that he was
dead
to me see to me this is why because
they're like oh we thought he was dead
and they're like oh well [ __ ] we're
going down for murder so now we have to
kill everybody I'm like do you see how
those two things don't make sense
because they were afraid that they were
going to be done for murder so let's
murder
three more people I'm like that I guess
they thought that they didn't have
anything to lose they wanted to
eliminate all the witnesses we'll get
away with it and I mean if that story
was true which like I said I kind of
doubt it I kind of feel like they were
probably like yeah we're just gonna kill
all these people and I think they made
up that whole thing to make it seem like
oh circumstances dictated I don't know I
wasn't there but I'm just saying it
seems like it seems like something that
you would say like to sort of mitigate
it a little bit to try to make yourself
seem in this like I did we didn't go in
there with the intention of killing
anybody but circumstances you know we
didn't mean for it to happen like that
but it just got out of control and it
escalated I kind of feel like it was
that kind of energy so yeah so he's like
okay so we have to eliminate all the
witnesses now because we think this dude
was dead which like I said if that was
true like he wouldn't have been dead and
everything I mean everything wouldn't
have been fine obviously because they
still would have got in trouble but now
they're in trouble for like former so
good job
uh so what they decided to do then was
they basically forced all four of the
people working at the Burger Chef to go
into Jane's car and then they drove to
the middle of town they dumped Jane's
Chevy Vega and then they got into
another car which was belonged to one of
the other people and then they drove
them to this 20 mile of the location and
shot all of them or killed all of them
now at this point I mean this seems
pretty definitive so the cops were kind
of like okay well this dude was
definitely involved
Forrester gave the names of three other
dudes that were allegedly allegedly
involved
but what ended up happening after that
was in 1986 one of the cops that was
working on the case leaked information
to the media about uh their ongoing
investigation and their whole
questioning of Forester and after it
went public Forrester stopped talking
so uh he's not only stopped talking but
he went back and said oh everything I
told you was I made that up so he
recanted
and because he was no longer cooperating
with them uh they couldn't really find
any more physical evidence and they
didn't have enough they probably had
enough maybe to prosecute him but they
wanted all of the dudes if indeed it was
that many people and because they didn't
have enough physical evidence for the
other ones they kind of like lost the
whole [ __ ]
and it turned out too that Forrester I
mean he was in prison for uh for other
[ __ ] so and he ended up dying in prison
in 2006 of cancer so they never did
figure out
um if he was actually the one that did
it if there was other people involved
um or if he was just like full of crap
because he didn't want to get moved to
the other prison so again this is even
though they're pretty sure like he did
know a lot of information about the that
checked out that doesn't necessarily
mean that he did it but it seems like
pretty and I don't think anybody else
has really come forward now they still
get tips about it like to this day
um you know this is a pretty famous case
in Speedway obviously because it's a
pretty small town and they don't have a
lot of other crimes uh so they're kind
of like just like in a lot of other you
know kind of uh big like unsolved
murders they're kind of looking into
using like DNA technology also I think
recently like 2018 2019 something like
that they actually release like some un
previously unpublished photos like from
the scene like of the knife blade that
they had found in Jane's uh sternum just
in the hopes that someone would
recognize it and they would be able to
get like new leads and everything but
other than that there has been like
nothing new since then and like I said
if it was Forester like he's dead like
he died a long time ago and they've I
don't as far as I know they've never
named the other three guys because they
didn't have enough evidence to bring
them in for questioning so I don't you
know so they never did name them uh so
even though that seems like a pretty
you know that proves like this seems
like a pretty plausible scenario but
the thing is though is he could have he
could have read about that case and then
made up a situation that's what I'm
saying to place himself in it there's no
way of actually knowing he did that
because he did have a motive for making
something up well you know and it's just
kind of a case where
that's the thing it's this is something
you always have to contend with is
they're like yeah there's always going
to be somebody that confesses to [ __ ]
yeah I mean I mean they did find the
[ __ ] in the in the septic tank and all
that and he did know where the bodies
were apparently
um but like I said I wasn't there so I
don't know if the cops maybe like gave
him that information and he was just
like giving back to them that's what I
mean like you don't really know because
you weren't there and then you know
there are a lot of there are a lot of
guilty people that will confess to other
[ __ ] that and when you really look down
to it you really look into it you're
like that Pride didn't go down that way
and I'm always [ __ ] reminded of
Albert Fish Albert Fish was a maniac
some of this yeah some of that [ __ ] he
really did
but some of the stuff that he talks
about there's no evidence that that
actually happened
there's a chance that Albert Fish lied a
lot serial killers lie a lot
well they a lot of them they are they
are pathological Liars well they're
self-aggrandize yeah and I think a lot
of it too is that because I mean
particular kinds of serial killers
because so much of their pathology is
based around fantasizing and like kind
of building this whole other identity
right
um a lot of times I don't know if they
actually know or if they can actually
distinguish between [ __ ] they actually
did and [ __ ] they just imagined or wish
that they did like we know that he ate a
little girl okay yeah we know that he
did a bunch of stuff yeah but he said
some stuff that there's no evidence for
that he basically bit some mentally
challenged dude's dick off there's no
evidence of that no one's come forth
with that
he also said that he this is Albert Fish
said that he found a little black boy
and beat him up and then raped and then
ended up killing him there's no evidence
of that there was no little I mean it
doesn't mean it didn't happen but
there's no body there's nobody there's
no complaint
uh you
fish probably thought he could just make
up anything and yeah they'd be like oh
all right yeah I guess you did do that
because he was he had a Jesus complex he
thought that the more he suffered the
greater he was he was a masochist like
crazy
yeah as all those needles he stuck into
his tank yeah he put needles up in his
tanks and [ __ ] and leaving him there
so um he would make up all kinds of
things about himself and uh no if he was
killing little children black or white
there would have been bodies they would
have been records and there was it
although he did eat some little girls
but that was easy to prove
yeah in that case well that's right and
I think that's they magnify what they do
yeah and I think that's what's
frustrating about like a lot of serial
killers is like I said I kind of feel
like yeah they do hate his [ __ ] but then
they lie about dude well because they
have like a very apparently they have a
really active Fantasy Life well look at
somebody like BTK Dennis yeah
um Dennis obviously did a lot of the
[ __ ] that they yeah you know he did all
that stuff but he had like lots of
projects yeah that he wanted to do that
he fantasized about that he wrote about
that he never did right so I kind of
feel like they have this whole it's
[ __ ] up like normal people have
fantasies about oh I'm gonna do this and
that and the other thing I'm going to
write that novel I'm gonna do this and
that and the other they have fantasies
about I'm gonna build a torture dungeon
and I'm gonna like hang a woman upside
down by her ankles and like eviscerate
her they have like fantasies like that
so sometimes they do the [ __ ] sometimes
it doesn't work out the way they want it
sometimes you know and so a lot of times
like some of the stuff that they say
they have kind of like a [ __ ] up they
have a weird thing where you know how
some people will pretend they're Navy
SEALS or say they have degrees they
didn't they didn't that's what they're
doing or like say they speak languages
they don't speak it's like that but
but with killing people and torturing
people like they're coming up with like
real creative [ __ ] right that they
probably didn't do yeah you commit a
crime there's going to be residue and
evidence Left Behind yeah you know
you're at least have missing persons now
there were a lot of missing people
but no what he would described there
would they would have known people would
have noticed that
I mean you'd think it was a different
time I'll give it that but it wasn't
that different it wasn't that different
I mean still if you left some bodies
laying around somebody was still gonna
do something about that you couldn't go
out and rape and murder little black
children and not [ __ ] call attention
to what you were doing [ __ ] cops back
then were like who's killing all these
[ __ ] little black kids they they yeah
it wasn't
you just couldn't get you just couldn't
do anything no yeah no I mean you could
get away with a lot more that's right
yeah but yeah you couldn't get away with
just like anything like yeah the reason
why you gotta wave a lot more is it
didn't have forensic science yeah nailed
down but they would have noticed there
would have been
you know records hey this woman her
child's missing and this woman her
child's missing it was all around the
same time and
the shit's suspicious and no kids didn't
go missing and unreported every mom
reported their kids missing stop it yeah
I mean yeah stop it yeah 99.99 times
it's not like I'm Black and I'm not
gonna report my child missing no that
didn't happen never happened they always
went to the authorities Debbie that's
still your kid that's your kid their
moms uh yeah right I mean unless the kid
was an orphan right or ran away from
somewhere and didn't have parents that's
not what that's somebody that's missed
that child yeah yeah it's a child yeah
and that is not what Albert Fish is
describing yeah I found a little black
boy and we had sex and then I killed him
you know no
but there's no missing where where is
this you know like I said that was fine
it doesn't happen that was something
that was something he wanted he
fantasized about and he just never got
it exercised about a bunch of [ __ ] so
and it's okay well we're using hibs as
an example an extreme example you can't
trust these
you can't trust [ __ ] Killers
especially when they're like what the
[ __ ] Henry Lee Lucas for crazy did we
do we did a show about that [ __ ]
they did a whole documentary about that
[ __ ] he killed people he killed
us he did he killed I think maybe two or
three people which is bad right yeah but
he confessed to every [ __ ] murder
that was unsolved yeah yeah I did that
[ __ ] once you I did that one too once
you have one life sentence and you're
happy with that because he was happy to
be in prison he liked it
he could have also he was kind of an
idiot yeah he was he was getting fed and
he had free plays to sleep and he could
have sex in there with [ __ ] dudes and
be a big man he would confess to [ __ ]
anything I mean for somebody like him it
was probably better to be in prison than
outside of it yeah because it's not like
he was having some big no life outside
no outside he was a bum right and fish
was kind of like that in a certain way
that [ __ ] was sick of this he
was he was miserable [ __ ] a fish you
know
he liked being punished he punished
himself you know you can't trust what it
would a dude like that says
and uh maybe with this guy he might have
been like that I don't know
you know difficult to say I I wouldn't I
wouldn't believe him
yeah physical happiness and I mean like
I said you can't because they do a lot
of [ __ ] up [ __ ] but you can't believe
every single thing they say because they
come up with all kind of crazy crap that
they just wanted to do but didn't get
around to
uh you know yeah grafter said when
really bad people would confess to a
heinous crime we used to call it the
urge to purge that reminds me of like
Heather's when she was when she was
doing the bulimia uh because even evil
people sometimes have a sliver of guilt
I kind of feel like it is because even
the worst serial killers maybe okay
maybe not like the the worst of the
worst but a lot of them do seem to have
because they'll do stuff for a long time
but then they'll do dumb [ __ ] and get
caught like I said look at BTK he did
all that [ __ ] and he got away with it
for a really long time but then he just
couldn't stop himself like after a while
he's like man nobody's talking about me
anymore uh you know I don't like not
being the center of attention so he had
to like start sending letters again like
oh I'm gonna kill people look out he
wanted to get caught he wanted to get
caught I kind of feel like a lot of them
do want to get caught
uh on some level maybe not the worst of
the worst but
I mean why would they do some of the
[ __ ] that they do if they didn't want to
get caught I'm just saying Mr 88 says
the Austin yogurt shot murder is very
very interesting case the book who
killed these girls but the case is
fantastic yeah I definitely want to uh
read that I've read like uh you know
portions of it because I wrote about it
a little bit for my book too but you
know grabther said some dudes love
prison life three hot meals a day warm
them to sleep in nice people to hang
with and the structure they need the
structure yeah I kind of feel like a
particular kind of person
you know I hate to say but like some of
these people's lives are probably like
super shitty outside and once they get
in there they're just kind of like ooh
you know they have a schedule every day
like I said they get fed they have some
nice place to sleep they can like
[ __ ] and some people need that and
some people like it and I kind of feel
like Henry Lee Lucas was one of those
people and he started confessing his
stuff because he knew that he would get
privileges if he did that because he's
like hey I'm helping them on a Case yeah
I killed this girl that you found and
Oklahoma or whatever yeah I totally did
that and he would just like make up
details now buy me a milkshake you know
what I mean it was that kind of [ __ ] so
you gotta watch and I mean I guess you
know obviously like uh the police like
authorities and stuff like that are
aware of this especially if
whoever it is that's in prison has
something to gain from confessing to a
crime uh you know you really gotta look
into that so that's why I think so this
guy Forrester it does sound like there
was enough outside evidence to maybe
look a little bit more into that because
he did seem to know where the how the
bodies were situated he did seem to say
like oh I threw the I flushed the 38
like the shells down the toilet and then
they found them so there was enough
there to like do something with
um so I don't know if he was completely
full of [ __ ] but he did have his own
motives as well so I guess it could have
gone either way but like I said we'll
never know because he died like in 2006
so there's that
uh granther said that him and Steve are
meeting up for beers at an Irish Pub on
Friday first time hanging out since
1989. oh okay cool yeah
tell him we said yeah there you go Steve
needs to come on the show I know that
[ __ ] is busy
we're all busy yeah and both you and
Steven to get on HRT I tell you man I'm
living the [ __ ] dream bro it's not a
dream it's reality but he's living but
uh
Steve Steve out of the blue [ __ ] 50
years old getting married and having
three kids with a [ __ ] 30 year old
woman you know he needs to be on HRT so
he can last long enough to raise those
kids
well you know yeah
all right so do you want to talk about
the Austin yogurt this time we're going
to talk about the Austin yoga man and
then after that you can talk about
whatever you want we'll check off after
that because uh I'll make us something
to eat
okay yeah but I did want to talk about
this because this is one of the cases
that I wanted to cover and I wrote about
this in my book actually already
so this actually happened a little bit
more recently this happened in 1991 in
Austin Texas also a quadruple murder so
it's kind of similar I think that's why
these suitcases are kind of like uh put
together a lot of times this is also a
quadruple murder like at a workplace
so the victims were
17 year old Eliza Thomas
and Jennifer Harbison who was also 17.
now they worked at the I Can't Believe
It's Yogurt store do you remember those
like I can't believe that's yogurt they
were like yeah I don't think they have
that anymore but they had uh TBI what
was that too good to Believe It's Yogurt
and that was called we had that in
Michigan TCBY TCBY is that what it is
yeah they were good too yeah that well
that was like the competitor for this
this one was called thank you camp guy
thank you thank you for 20 bucks okay
thank you very much for the super chats
we the show runs on super chats if you
all would like to uh tip Jenny Super her
hard work patreon we would very much
appreciate it and can't go out and get
your shirts out for you soon yeah we
just had a problem with this he's got a
way for the [ __ ] die to come I think
the ink is coming Friday okay and the
and the shirts and the new shirts should
be here tomorrow so we should be able to
get those mailed out over the weekend
yeah
we can now ship and wave from here we
have a [ __ ] hole I got a printer I
got the whole we got a scale post I got
a scale I got a whole postage set up so
I don't have to go to the Post well
because the post office here doesn't
like I said it doesn't have the the
self-serve [ __ ] I'd rather do that from
home anyways it's much easier I mean you
know well especially now that we kind of
like live far away right from you know
it's not convenient anymore now uh
Maniac 67 broccoli and cheddar cheddar
cheese quiche I love quiche I do too
I've made many quiche all the time I
haven't made a quiche in a long time
yeah medication a long time well it's
because eggs are so expensive I gotta go
up there and get me a case of eggs
uh once you get a case of eggs I'll make
some quiche there's probably a farm
around here that'll sell you some eggs
see here's the thing man no one else is
good it's [ __ ] uh uh cheese and
cheese broccoli and and Gulf Shrimp
[ __ ] it's mixing fantastic quiche
real good
but you gotta eat it up yeah you gotta
eat it up love quiche yeah I do too yeah
uh but yeah man don't eat quiche and
I'll bust a [ __ ] in the mouth
for saying that yeah what's wrong if I'm
not a real man I [ __ ] love Keys hell
yeah she's [ __ ] good if you're a real
man you won't give a [ __ ] about it any
like what anybody else says
not tell you what a real man eats eat
and drink whatever the [ __ ] you want to
that's what a real man does yeah they
don't worry about it rambled egg pie all
right very good very good
I mean you know I love it anything you
could do with eggs I love eggs look I'm
gonna tell you all something
I got a big old yield of sweet potatoes
in
and as I was [ __ ] taking the sweet
potatoes in
all the little greens that are the
little leaves that come off the top of
it I pulled them all I picked them
and I I cooked them as Pollock with a
[ __ ] uh Pollock like kind of like
Pollock paneer but didn't have paneer it
didn't even use [ __ ] cheese I'm
basically I turned it I treat them as
spinach and they're better than spinach
it was good when I made an Indian dish
out yeah you can make SOG paneer out of
them Pollock paneer whatever uh instead
of paneer I had [ __ ] pork tenderloin
which I don't think the Indians or the
[ __ ] Muslims would eat that no but it
worked it was still good I didn't have
any
if you grow sweet potatoes the greens
that come off the top are better than
spinach I mean hopefully they're not
poisoned you did look right oh yeah no a
chicken
no they said they're great they're great
yeah they're good they're great uh very
similar to spinach they tastes similar
spinach more tender a little slightly
sweeter not quite as bitter but real
good off the top of sweet potatoes sweet
potato vines yeah so uh that'd make a
good pizza topping actually instead of
uh you know instead of spinach like
spinach on top of pizza
but I'm gonna work with that once I get
that [ __ ] rolled yeah we got to do
something with the sweet potatoes what
are you gonna do with this week next
time uh some of it's gonna be sweet
potato pie okay that's that's okay
that's acceptable rest of it will just
be side dishes
um next time I will have three times
that amount because we can make sweet
potato fries with it I could do that uh
I learned a better way to make the yield
because
next time we'll be in the next 90 days
we'll have three times that
I'm just saying you can make sweet
potato fries in the air fryer yeah
or chips you can make like potato chips
yeah they're no they don't crisp up
quite as much we'll see we'll see what I
can do they'd still be good though I
think there will be all right it'll be a
little bit soggy
that's okay
uh actually the little uh the little
ones that were kind of like [ __ ]
irregular I'm gonna [ __ ] render those
down into into uh sweet potato pie yeah
well that's good too that's good too
about the same as pumpkin pie yeah
yeah so uh so I Can't Believe It's
Yogurt was I kind of feel like that was
the com the competing chain to TCBY
which stands for I think this can't be
yogurt or that can't be yogurt I
remember we had a TCBY I don't think we
had a I Can't Believe It's Yogurt but
they were I mean you know that was like
a really big thing like in the late 80s
and early 90s like yogurt shops that
were like oh it's kind of like ice cream
there was that so there was like a
couple of other chains that were going
what hold on Mango says he's talking
about you got to make your own Kishi I'm
doing that camp says you gotta cure soup
yeah no nine days and the sweet potato
will get sweeter so I know all of that
nine days at least they're talking about
how much is full of sweet potatoes are
very healthy and all four vitamins yeah
yeah yeah I know all that we're gonna
look all it it's gonna be great
and they're delicious and it's Southern
Southern as [ __ ] I'm just growing things
that mostly do super well in the south
eggplant just keeps paying off I got
more eggplant than I can use almost like
I said we had to make a whole other
thing of Baba ganous making baba ganoush
with it which I had something I had some
last night it was real good yeah with
with a little bit of roasted eggplant
dip with [ __ ] cumin and and roasted
um uh uh uh [ __ ] what do you call it
onions and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you should put this yogurt but I was
used to sour cream instead because I had
some but no we don't have we don't have
any because we used to get those big
things of yogurt from the Indian store
but we haven't been to the Indians I can
make yogurt but yogurt's actually
cheaper to buy right now than it is to
make yeah I can make yogurt in the
[ __ ] like I said if you go to if you
go to the Asian market like the Indian
market they have those big things yeah
they're pretty cheap yeah I gotta get uh
uh [ __ ] culture like a yeast culture
it's a special one that you need to do
to make yogurt
I could do it but I don't really give a
[ __ ] enough because I have I have sour
cream you know and it's actually quite
good enough you know
yeah I mean well a lot of stuff you want
to make from scratch but some stuff you
don't really need to because the
difference isn't really worth it it's
not really worth it like worth the extra
effort yeah you know you just gotta like
where do you want to spend your time
yeah in India the Middle East they would
use sour cream if they had it but
they're using yogurt
we don't have any right at the moment
sometimes we have some but yeah we
haven't had it everybody wants to talk
about food now we can't talk about food
unless you get [ __ ] soup well we'll
talk about food like after every day I
kind of figured this would happen
because we're talking about horrible
murders you guys that talked about
at food please because everybody on this
[ __ ] show loves food I can't
understand well everybody said why you
eat why do you eating don't eat
that's the thing well why do you feel
like food is there it brings us all
together you gotta eat everybody's gotta
eat that's like I subscribe to a channel
on YouTube that has [ __ ] um
pakistanis tribal pakistanis
trying Western food and they tried spam
Halal spam which is the [ __ ] beef
base and they [ __ ] loved it they
totally understood it and I have [ __ ]
westerners people from America attacking
me for [ __ ] like a spam
spam is good if you know what to do with
it I still don't like spam I don't hate
it but it's just I don't know it's just
too it tastes too salty and chemical you
have to slice it thin and then you have
to cook it I know I got it like that
it's still it's still it's too salty it
is salty they said it was salty it's too
salty even in Pakistan they said it was
salty but they still liked it it said
because you don't have to add salt if
you put it in the rice and I'm not a
verse to Salt look look [ __ ] I have low
blood but my doctor told me you should
eat more salt because my blood
pressure's so low but um I don't like
real real salties I like some salty [ __ ]
but I don't like Robo salty [ __ ] not
usually you just don't add any salt to
the dish there are things that you can
do with Spam
manga says yep murder makes us hungry
yeah yeah I guess and well and like I
said because these are happening at fast
food restaurants even though the food
doesn't really have anything to do with
it but like I said you can talk about
food after I'm done with talking about
yeah just just he admitted she probably
spam low uh loaf once yeah that's good
all right yeah like I said I'm not I
don't hate it it's just not
if you know if I
um I just probably would never eat it
like if you weren't around I would know
it's just it's just
um pork shoulder it's well I know I know
it is it's not anything like alien or
anything like that it's just nothing
it's nothing that I would eat if I yeah
if I was left in my own devices it's
actually like a mid-quality cut it's not
like you're talking about tripe or
[ __ ] internal organs or anything it's
just the shoulder pork shoulder that's
all it is it's [ __ ] cooked take it
off the bone and then kind of
re-processed and cooked into a [ __ ]
can so it's shelf stable it powered
World War II
riff tracks did a short yeah that was a
Hormel short yeah and uh it's half an
hour long it's on YouTube for free if
you want to watch it it's super fun uh
and they actually show you like uh how
they make Spam among other things like
among other Hormel the low sodium
options are a lot better from like
Butchery all the way down to like
canning low sodium options then they got
a bunch of flavored ones that are good
they have a tune they have a [ __ ] uh
um turkey one that I have but I haven't
tried it
it's probably not good I don't turkey
isn't good but I just it was cheap so I
bought it honestly I don't really mind
like ground turkey and stuff like that I
used to put ground turkey in like
spaghetti sauce and all that kind of
stuff and it's like I always thought it
was good I like turkey and but you just
have to cook it slightly different
because it's not as oily it's not you
know there's not as much fat in it
so you just gotta like uh cook it
slightly differently okay we got to get
our food people okay let's get back to
this like I said it's like this is not a
hugely hugely long case I'm just like
you know what I mean it's like we can
talk about food after it's like okay you
keep getting like getting all distracted
yeah yeah like like you and your ADHD no
I gotta do it or whatever you don't got
it I gotta do it you don't gotta do it
you don't got to do it okay I'm not
gonna do it then I'm gonna okay I'm
gonna stop all right so
all right where were we okay so we have
two 17 year old girls Eliza Thomas and
Jennifer Harbison now they worked at
this I Can't Believe It's Yogurt store
and this is in the hillside strip mall
uh on West Anderson Lane in Austin Texas
so December 6th of 1991 they were
working the closing shift
now Eliza's parents had uh dropped by
the shop like the mom and the dad like
separately to check on their daughter uh
at separate times between 9 30 and 10 pm
now at some point before the store
closed
Jennifer had a 15 year old sister named
Sarah
and Sarah had a 13 year old friend named
Amy Amy Ayers and they both came to the
shop as well they had actually been at
the North Cross Mall which was down the
street they had been hanging out there
all evening
so all four of the girls were actually
going to do a sleepover that night like
at the Harbison house and Sarah and Amy
were just like waiting at the at the
TCBY it wasn't TCBY I was I Can't
Believe It's Yogurt same deal you're
right
um they were waiting there because they
were going to get a ride home like with
the older girls we're all going to go
back to the same house and we're gonna
do a sleepover
now the shop closed at 11 PM
cash register was closed out at 1103
with a no sale tag
about 45 minutes after that so about
quarter to 12.
there was a cop who was cruising by the
strip mall and noticed that the yogurt
shop was on fire
so he calls the fire department
obviously
six minutes later uh the firefighters
arrive
they forced their way into the store and
they discovered that all four of the
girls had been murdered
and stacked on top of one another damn
stacked my black cord wood and then the
place was set on fire all four of them
were naked damn and had been bound and
gagged with pieces of their own clothing
I wonder if they were raped two of them
were Nuka two of them were
now okay so the cops trying to piece
together what happened uh now initially
the scene had been processed as a fire
and not as a homicide so when the
firefighters first went in there
obviously they didn't know it was a
murder at first so they didn't really
really take care to you know they didn't
like secure it as a homicide because
they didn't know until a few minutes
later
so some of the evidence was lost or
contaminated or whatever
so what they were able to determine at
least in the early stages was that at
least two assailants had either come
into the store after closing they didn't
break in uh but they had maybe come to
the store after closing or probably more
likely had forced the girls into the
stock room at gunpoint
now they initially thought that robbery
was going to be the motive but
there was a bank bag full of money found
underneath the front counter apparently
they had put the money in the thing at
the end of the day and they were going
to take and drop it off the bank like
you do at the closing shift uh and that
was not taken
um there was some cash was taken from
the premises but not this big bag of
money
um some sources I've seen like a couple
different sources on this some said only
14 was taken from the register some said
it was five hundred dollars but they
didn't take like all the best big bag of
money that was underneath the counter so
robbery maybe maybe not the uh main
motive
so they did autopsies on the four
victims uh two of them Amy uh the 13
year old and Jennifer who was I believe
17 uh had been raped
all of them had been shot in the head
either a 22 or a 380 caliber
semi-automatic pistol
Amy Amy had been shot twice uh maybe
because she'd struggled it was also
theorized that she maybe because the
bullet um actually should been shot in
the head but initially it had missed her
brain and her body was actually found a
little bit away from the other ones so
they thought that maybe she hadn't died
outright yeah and that she had maybe
tried to crawl away like they had
thought she was dead and stacked her on
top of the other one set ever set them
on fire and then she tried to like crawl
away but she didn't make it that far
which is [ __ ] horrific to like think
about but they thought that was like
their Theory anyway
now uh so yeah they had stocked up the
bodies and started a fire in the corner
nearest to the victims
um I think they probably found some
evidence that maybe an accelerant had
been used but it was like inconclusive
but maybe it was lighter the liquid well
yeah everybody knows everybody's watches
True Crime [ __ ] they know what it says
like maybe like lighter fluid or yeah
lighter fluid gasoline something like
that
uh yeah now so the cops obviously this
was [ __ ] horrific so the cops are
under enormous pressure to solve the
case pretty much as quickly as possible
now like in any case you get a bunch of
and one as high profile as this you get
like a bunch of weird ass false
confessions and a bunch of like leads
that don't go anywhere uh but they did
get a few promising leads in the days
following the murders
most of these came from a dude whose
name was I think his name was Daryl
Croft
now he uh had been a police officer I
believe he was retired and he had
actually been in the shop like eating
some yogurt uh a couple hours before the
girls were killed so a couple hours
before closing a little while before
closing
he said that while he was in there he
had seen a couple of like uh what he
thought were suspicious looking
individuals
one of them wearing a large green jacket
that looked kind of like Army fatigues
and he was kind of walking off toward
the rear of the shop
and Croft this witness said that he had
asked Eliza Thomas like one of the girls
who would later be killed uh Hey where's
that guy going Eliza said oh he's just
going to use the bathroom
Croft also said that this guy in the
Green Jacket had come out of the
bathroom and he sat at a booth with this
other guy who was wearing a black jacket
now the first guy in the army fatigue
looking jacket said uh the witness said
he was about five foot six had dirty
blonde hair he said the second guy was
like a bigger dude like with a black
jacket on
he said both the guys looked like they
were a little bit older like maybe in
their late 20s or early 30s and he said
when he left the shop at about quarter
to 11 about 10 47 uh that they were both
definitely still there and he had
thought that they were suspicious at the
time and he came forward like after the
murder happened and told police about it
uh neither of these men spoiler alert
has ever been identified
but
um here's here's what ended up happening
with this
so even though neither of those two guys
was identified the cops did hone in on a
suspect pretty quickly and this was a
guy who was 16 at the time his name was
Maurice Pierce
now he was picked up at the Northcross
Mall the same mall that the uh girls
have been hanging out at earlier that
day
and he was carrying around a 22 caliber
pistol
so he got questioned about the yogurt
shop murders and Maurice says I don't
know anything about that but I do know
like a couple of my buddies yeah I think
they did that [ __ ]
he says that his friend a 15 year old
Forest Wellborn he had he borrowed a gun
and he did that [ __ ]
uh oh and also two of my other friends
uh Michael Scott who was 17 and Robert
Springsteen who was also 17 uh they had
actually done the [ __ ] he's like I
wasn't there but they told me about it
later on they were the ones that did it
now they did a ballistics test on the 22
which they found in Maurice Pierce's
possession uh this did not appear to
match the firearm used in the killings
but this didn't stop the cops from
corralling all four of the Young Dudes
into custody and started grilling them
about this quadruple homicide like I
said they were under a lot of pressure
to solve this because I mean you know
this is like the random murder of like
three teenage girls or four teenage
girls rather and uh you know so
everybody wanted them to solve it
now I will note here that a large
portion of the interrogation
was handled by a dude named officer
Hector Polanco
later this guy would actually be
temporarily suspended from the force the
hell was that Thunder okay
after it came to light that he had
actually coerced confessions in a 1988
rape and murder case he later did get
reinstated but he didn't have the best
reputation uh vis-a-vis
um strong arming people into confessing
to [ __ ] they maybe did or did not do
just gonna say that
so these four kids teenagers
were uh interrogated for many many hours
and they eventually all four of them
confessed to
doing the crime
but it should be noted that their
confessions were a little bit
contradictory
and from the reports that came out later
it does seem that at times the police
were sort of like uh coaching them a
little bit allegedly you know uh just
saying they were kind of like they would
kind of feed them details and then if
they didn't like answer the question
correctly like the cop would be like hey
don't you mean this yeah totally that's
what I meant it was that kind of thing
you know what I'm saying
so even after the confessions Maurice
Pierce who was the original uh kid that
had the gun
and Forest Welborn uh they never got
prosecuted because the grand jury
thought well there wasn't like really
enough evidence to uh you know to try
them but the cases against the other two
the 17 year olds Michael Scott and
Robert Springsteen they went right ahead
even though like I said not really any
physical evidence really kind of all
they had was the confessions but they
went ahead with it and amazingly uh
Springsteen got convicted in 2001 and
was given a death sentence damn uh
Michael Scott convicted in 2002 and got
life in prison uh because he was only he
you know he was still only a minor at
the time the crimes were committed
now uh as I said it seems that they
didn't really have any evidence other
than the confessions and there's
evidence that maybe these confessions
might have been coerced
so in 2006 uh Springsteen's confection
actually a conviction actually got
confection I was thinking about candy
yeah uh conviction actually got
overturned uh because they deemed that
his original trial was unfair there was
like some kind of like little legal
thing that they kind of went into there
thank you mango mango so it can hide and
spam oh yeah yeah oh I see it I'm a
little bit behind yeah
I'm a little bit behind welcome Sarah
yeah hey can't believe uh I've missed
most of the live feed for work yeah well
that's okay well it's always there you
can listen to it later on I know I know
it's more fun to like be here live but
you know yeah
yeah
um so yeah so 2006 Springsteen's
conviction got overturned 2008
um actually the Scots and Springsteen's
attorneys they wanted some more like
stringent DNA testing because obviously
DNA was a lot more uh was a lot better
than it had been during the original
trial
so they had the DNA comparison to the
DNA because they did recover some DNA
from the scene because like I said two
of the victims had been raped and they
were able to get DNA from that so they
did a DNA profile of the perpetrator or
perpetrators
and the DNA
that they found did not match any of the
four teenagers that were originally
suspected of this crime
so at this point uh both Michael Scott
and uh Springsteen were released in
2009.
crazily though this is how life goes
sometimes
Maurice Pierce in 2010
it was his firearm possession that had
first like led the authorities to
questioning them in the first place
because he was walking around this mall
where the girls had been earlier in the
day and he had a 22 in his pocket or
wherever the [ __ ] and he was the one
that had caused him to bring in the
people to start with
so 2010 Maurice Pierce
uh he gets pulled over in a just a
regular ass traffic stop in Austin Texas
Pierce
uh took off running
and he got tackled by a cop named Frank
Wilson
and during the struggle he ended up
stabbing the cop the cop was not killed
uh he did recover
but
um
during the struggle
Wilson actually shot Maurice Pierce dead
so whether or not Maurice Pierce was
responsible
for the Austin yogurt shop murders which
I don't know like I said it seems
doubtful but that doesn't mean he was
necessarily a good person I'm not saying
that but he did he basically did get
shot by the cops after getting pulled
over but he did stab a cop first so you
know that's that's kind of fair play
now as I said Frank Wilson did recover
eventually recover from his injuries
so
I don't know I kind of feel like some
there are some researchers out there
that still think yeah these four
teenagers they at least knew something
about it or even if they weren't like
directly responsible but I don't know I
feel like the DNA evidence probably like
exonerates them because the DNA that
they found doesn't seem to match any of
the four of them and two of the girls
were raped so I'm imagining that that's
pretty definitive
now for a while there was another theory
going around that
um that maybe the four girls had been
killed by a serial killer named Kenneth
McDuff uh he's also known as the
broomstick murderer by the way
he had actually been convicted in 1966
of three murders but in 1989 he was
paroled and a lot of people think that
he committed a whole bunch more murders
after he was paroled like after he got
released
now this guy uh originally he kind of
like yeah I did the yogurt shop murders
like he confessed to it but he later
recanted that confession so it might
have been a case I don't know if he like
knew any other information about it that
would make him be like a more viable
suspect or if he was just like
bullshitting and talking [ __ ]
when he recanted though he said a really
[ __ ] up thing he's like oh if I
actually had done that I would have been
proud of it and I'm like
good for you I'm just what the [ __ ] like
I don't yeah it's whatever absolutely
like I said if you're gonna be a serial
killer that's bad enough but don't be
like a some smug like brag bragging ass
[ __ ] on top of it that's just
like that's like the cherry on top of
the [ __ ] Sunday like I said it's just
kind of like Jesus Christ so yeah oh if
I'd done that I would have been proud of
it I'm like yeah good for you whatever
Edge Lord so uh so Kenneth McDuff
whether he did the yogurt shop murders
or or not like I said I don't think
there's any other evidence not saying he
wasn't a [ __ ] Lord because he was but
you know he killed lots of other people
but he actually got executed uh in 1998
uh and that was for like a separate
murder like I said
now the only thing that I've seen about
this case lately because I do try to
keep up I mean I wrote I wrote about
this in my book and like I do try to
like kind of keep up with stuff but it's
hard because I wrote about a lot of
cases in there and it's hard to like
keep up with all the updates the most
recent thing I've I've seen about this
particular case was in February of this
year like 2022 and I was excited because
I was like ooh like you know I was like
Austin yogurt shop murders like news
from this year and I saw something come
up and I was like ooh maybe they found
something out but all they announced in
the article was that oh yeah
um we're applying new DNA technology to
this I'm assuming it's going to be the
same kind of stuff they use in the
Golden State killer case and all that
kind of stuff like they're doing like
the ancestry type [ __ ] so I imagine
that's what they're doing that's not
what they said but that's what I'm
assuming
um so they said yeah we're bringing that
to bear on it so we're closer than ever
to solving this crime and that's
basically like all they said and I was
just kind of like okay well that's not
really all that helpful is it but maybe
they are still trying to solve it I know
they can't really like say anything
without thing but at least
these I mean these two particular crimes
um you know even though particularly the
Burger Chef murders because that
happened like back in 1978
um you know the Austin yogurt shop
murders that was still a long time ago
but that was more recent it was 1991 but
at least with the Advent of all this new
DNA technology and stuff like that like
I said how they caught D'Angelo and all
that [ __ ] so at least it does seem like
now they have some new Tools in their
Arsenal like to sort of solve these cold
cases finally and like finally put them
to bed
um because they're just
so many I mean like I said it was you
look at I had three books full of the
[ __ ] and there was like a whole bunch of
[ __ ] that I left out yeah there's just
so many that are never solved and it's
really really sad that's the weird thing
about these [ __ ] murders
they haven't been solved we have the
technology to solve them now
but a lot of times the victims long dead
and then the people that care about the
victims are now dead
I know isn't that sad it's weird when
you think about it but it's been that
way for thousands and thousands of years
yeah you know so uh you can kill a
person and get away with it yeah
and I yeah and it's like and I don't
know like I'm sure it's like better than
it used to be but probably not that much
better not that much better no and for
whatever reason I'm like really
fascinated by unsolved murders from like
the early like the late 19th century in
the early 20th century and I think I may
be fascinated by those because probably
those will never be solved never because
it's like everyone's Dead all of the
physical evidence is gone yeah you know
what I mean like in most cases like Jack
the Ripper and [ __ ] I think that's why
there's so much stuff about that because
you'll probably never solve that they're
still interesting cases yeah they are
but the victim's families are long gone
I mean even their descendants are long
gone
the cops involved in it were long gone
that's what I mean everyone's dead
they're all dead so it's just and that's
but that like I I think that's why I
find them fascinating because that's
like really really sad to me yeah
because it's like well it's sad to me
because you know that murder victim that
was like somebody's kid you know that
was somebody's spouse that was
somebody's and like the you know their
families like never found out what
happened to them like they died without
ever knowing and we still don't know
time it's a [ __ ] time is a [ __ ]
you can't beat it it's a [ __ ]
eventually time just [ __ ] conquers
all but I mean at least these two cases
yeah I mean they're old but they're not
that old I mean these both still
happened in our lifetimes and we're not
that old I mean we're old but we're not
that old so I mean some of the people
like these people's families and [ __ ]
like that are still around yeah and some
of the cops that worked on it some of
the witnesses that worked on it are
still around so I'm kind of hoping that
now that DNA is like better that like
more of this [ __ ] will be solved like
they'll kind of get it together yeah
like I know they have new [ __ ] to work
on too because more people are getting
murdered all the time unfortunately but
you know they seem to have a better
track record of catching them now
but maybe they always had that
I don't know I kind of feel like like I
said I was thinking about this because
and I think I wrote this in the intro to
one of my books because I was looking at
the statistics about how many cases were
solved versus unsolved and you would
think that like nowadays more cases
would be solved because of DNA and all
that kind of stuff yeah it's like
swarming [ __ ] guys world is ending out
there not really it wasn't even that bad
come on
um calm down let me make a show
but the thing but I read somewhere that
it's like oh statistically like it was
more likely for cases to be solved like
back in the 50s 60s 70s well not the 70s
but like I think like pre-1950s than now
but I think that might be a little bit
I don't think that's for the reason that
people think it might be I don't think
that's for the reason that you know oh
police work was so much better back then
or there weren't as many murders I don't
think that's the case I think the cases
that back then if you confess to a
murder they were kind of like good done
print it yeah put them in prison like
they didn't they couldn't check right
they didn't have DNA so I kind of feel
like a lot of times they were just kind
of like yeah you look like the guy that
did it and they throw you in jail and be
like solved
so I kind of feel like maybe that's what
it was in general in the modern era
a crime is usually solved more or less
in the first 48 hours
you know basically who did it you know
why they did it I mean Rosa complains
most of them are in that first 48-hour
time period Well because most people who
most people are killed by somebody that
they know most people yeah not everybody
obviously right otherwise we wouldn't
even be here we wouldn't be talking
about this right
but most of the time well that's what I
said like every time a woman gets
murdered they're like look 85 90 95 of
the time that's their husband or their
boyfriend or an ex-boyfriend as the as
the investigation goes beyond three days
after 48 hours
the the the chances of that
investigation finding the culprit that
did it diminishes
just not impossible but impossible but
it did I mean yeah it does happen well
that's why they should that's why they
called that show 48 Hours yeah because
that's the most important because that's
the time when everybody's memory is like
because all the witnesses are kind of
like yeah grafters is in the comments
section he can chime in but most of them
90 of them you know at the time who
killed this person
like 90 of them
you know who did it it's right there
so
that's why remember what we're talking
about in cases like this are the
outliers yeah well and to be like I said
that's what it's always been so
fascinating because it's so tragic is
that yeah 90 95 of the time somebody
gets murdered which is always terrible
but it's like most of the time there was
a reason or they know who they have a
good idea even if they can't convict the
person they have a good idea who it
probably was but
I'm kind of like fascinated by murders
that seem to like have
no motive at all like you know what I
mean like well like I said like serial
killers or where it's just like random
well we already covered cases that
happened back in the 1800s just where
you'd find an entire family in a home
killed with an ax
although well I'm I'm writing an article
about that right now all the mirrors in
the house covered up yeah
and you don't know they still haven't
solved that [ __ ] no and that was that
was [ __ ] over a hundred years ago
that was 1912. yeah 110 years ago and
you don't know who that was yeah like I
said I'm writing an article about that
yeah somebody just walked into a
farmhouse with an ax and killed
everybody in there for some reason
well like I said I'm writing an article
about that because that's going to be
like the second video that's going up on
my uh True Crime Channel yeah
um I'm not just gonna be talking about
Villisca I'm going to be talking about
all the other ax murders that have
because it was a lot of Xmas back then
you guys and there was like a whole
series of them
because they think one of the theories
is that the Villisca murders was maybe a
serial killer because it was a whole
bunch of other ax murders that happened
like 1911 1912 in the midwest that were
very very similar to what happened at
Villisca so yeah I'm kind of I'm doing a
video about that like I'm working on it
right now but yeah because I wrote about
it in my book too but that's always been
like really bad because I feel like a
lot of people know about Villisca but a
lot of people don't know about like the
[ __ ] ton of other ax murders yeah that
happened right around that same time
period and that were maybe the same dude
yeah and here's the weird thing
this show is kind of a North America
United States centered show
there's a [ __ ] ton of them never solved
y'all can't even barely grasp what
happened in [ __ ] Central and South
America
the entire world
a lot of murders happened
and the unsolved everywhere
it kind of makes you feel like [ __ ]
life is very cheap
well the think about it like I think
about this a lot because like I said I
read a lot about True Crime I write
about a lot so this is something that
I've given a lot of thought to yeah now
as much as it does kind of seem like
that
I feel like it's less like that than it
used to be back in the old days because
like if you think about
back in the day like prior to the 20th
century let's say
um
I kind of feel like life was way cheaper
back then yeah it was
I mean look at yeah we talk about like
Jack the Ripper and everybody talks
about that but it's just kind of like
the thing about it is like the the only
reason that people remember Jack the
Ripper from that era like it was a flash
was was because they were flashy yeah
they I mean they were very very uh you
know the the women were eviscerated like
left in the middle of the street and
there was like the letters like the
communication yeah so it was like a big
deal but there was a [ __ ] ton of other
murders that happened back then that
weren't maybe quite as sexy just if you
want to use that
um strangled a bunch of strangled
strangled poisons you know stabbed yeah
um that happened all the time yeah but
you just don't hear about it and like I
said a lot of times it was never solved
or they couldn't prove it and you just
don't hear about it because it wasn't as
like you said like it wasn't as flashy
right it was just flashy so
you know we've talked about this before
I kind of talk about people talking
about the good old days and stuff like
that but that was yeah there's no such
thing there's no such thing it was a
more Primal time it was more like
something out of those old [ __ ]
novels that you read and it was also
kind of
the wild west at the same time
and you think like well that was back in
the old days that was actually kind of
the Baseline most of human history was
like that we're in a time that is more
exceptional at least in the west where
there is
a modern criminal justice system and
modern technology to try to uh do the
investigation to figure out who did it
that's not that was not what what
reality was
in the 1900s and in the 1800s and Beyond
you just kind of had to use you had kind
of had to guess or you had to know
who it was well this person died and we
know that that one did it you know we're
gonna go up to that person and they may
have been wrong
yeah and I'm sure a lot of times they
probably are well they're wrong nowadays
yeah like with all the stuff they have
right so I'm sure back then they were
just kind of like yeah that person looks
guilty let's hang them yeah it was fun
yeah that doesn't have motive that
person had had motive so they did it
well look one of the ax Martyrs that I
was writing about that may or may not be
related to Villisca
it was a whole family again it was it
was actually six people this it was two
families they lived next door to each
other and this happened in uh Colorado
Springs I think
and uh you know it'll it'll all be on
the site and then the video and
everything but so it was two families
that were killed with an ax same kind of
thing as baliska blunts out of the ax
like Windows covered up all that kind of
stuff
so that happened and originally the
person that they fingered for the crime
was the husband of the woman that was
killed because it was the woman or the
two kids and the husband was in a
hospital because he had consumption I
think so he was like at a sanatorium or
something the Assumption usually meant
cancer a lot of times well no it's
tuberculosis I thought it was cancer no
it's tuberculosis consumption's
tuberculosis okay yeah that's just what
they used to call it and he died of it
later on but he was in a hospital for
that and they arrested him as far as I
could determine like from old newspapers
at the time just because when they
brought him to the scene and said hey
here's your wife and three and
six-year-old child who've been you know
bludgeoned to death with an ax and he
didn't like seem upset enough
um so they arrested him but I mean they
found out that it couldn't have been him
later on because they were like no he
was at the hospital where he always is
like you know what I mean they like they
had like zillions of people that saw
where he was so um so there was that but
yeah back then you just looked at
somebody funny and they'd be like oh
well you murdered somebody obviously
they didn't really need it well they
didn't have any forensic technology so
what are they gonna do that's like all
he's like hey that's some weirdo that we
don't know like they just came in town
they're a stranger it must be them right
because nobody who lives here would do
anything like that right you know what I
mean so that's why that's why I think
that prior to maybe like 1960 or I can't
remember what year with the cutoff was
but they were saying like prior to 1960
let's say uh you know the the rate of
like crimes that were solved was like
way way higher than now I was like I
don't think that that's
saying anything I don't think that's
saying what you think it's saying I
think it's because a lot of people were
probably like wrongly uh wrongly
convicted because I think that's what
that is because they didn't really have
anything to back it up somebody
confessed to some [ __ ] or you just like
looked evil or whatever and then they
would just be like yep you did it bye
solved
you know next I think it was I think it
was that so you know
oh they're talking about
um we should do a show about they're
talking about Israel Keys we did a show
about Israel keys I kind of feel like
he's and her bomb monster and her bowel
monster I kind of feel like those two
[ __ ] are really bad serial
killers that not a lot of people talk
about I kind of feel like that's they're
not like the big like Ted Bundy and BTK
and all those like everybody knows those
but I kind of feel like Israel keys and
uh you know in her bowmeister and stuff
like that they did like really [ __ ] up
[ __ ] too but it's like you hardly hear
anybody talking about them and I don't
know why because they did like really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] all right there was some
creepy [ __ ] he had that that's what I
mean I don't understand why I don't
understand why he's not better now he
had that whole [ __ ] pool with all the
mannequins around it that was funny and
his [ __ ] house is home didn't he own
Dollar Dollar General Store it wasn't
Dollar General it was um it was one that
we don't have anymore yeah it wasn't
because the Dollar Tree no no no no no
it was like I said it's one that we
don't have
it did but it wasn't like a national
change okay you know what I'm saying
it wasn't International he's making a
bunch of money but he was killing gays
he was gay killing his own kind
well that's usually what serial killers
do they kill whoever who they're ever
they're sexually attracted yeah so if
you're gay and you're a serial killer
then you're gonna take your own games
then you're gonna kill like people that
you're attracted to yeah just like
straight serial killers will kill women
right
and pedophiles will kill children yeah
that's just kind of that's how they roll
because that's about like I said it's
like mostly sexual for them what so yeah
I don't understand like why mostly
that's what I mean that's what I don't
understand like why why he's not better
known I don't know why Israel key isn't
better now because he killed the [ __ ]
out of people well Baumeister isn't
better known because he didn't remain a
mystery for very long I mean he killed
himself
once they identified it he went on the
Run that's true then he killed himself
I think he would have made he'd make a
great movie actually have you made a
movie about Israel I'd be very surprised
if they had Israel Keys that's not his
name his name is Herbert her bellmeister
yeah I was looking at someone else yeah
he's made a great movie because he had
that [ __ ] spooky ass mansion and they
have clips of him like he was
interviewed because he was like a big
like respected local businessman so
there's like clips of him on YouTube
look it up where he's like he was
interviewed by the news like talking
about his house and his like business
and everything it's like oh it's creepy
yeah he had a big old man like knowing
what you know about what the what the
[ __ ] did and he was killing all these
little Zachary's and [ __ ] um Zach is
like what yeah exactly what killing all
these Zachary's and uh and [ __ ]
putting their bones out by it uh where
it was what kind of what kind of
building was that isn't it called Fox
Hollow Farm yeah isn't that his house
and he was putting the bones out by
where they would they still find bones
there nowadays as far as I know wasn't
it by where they put the wood like a
where the firewood was or where was it
something like that well I think he was
like spreading them out all over the
[ __ ] property creepy [ __ ]
and then later on how long he got away
with that they had a really good
Paranormal Witness to where people moved
into that house afterwards
and it's supposedly haunted as [ __ ] I'm
telling you if any place I don't really
believe in that [ __ ] usually but it's
like if any place is haunted it's
probably that place yeah not gonna lie I
had a dude living in the [ __ ] um
caretakers quarters
and you heard somebody knocking at the
door screaming help me help me
opens up the door there's nobody there
yeah weird [ __ ] was happening man that's
a bummer that's like a bummer like
because he had a Serial Killer's
Paradise going on out in that [ __ ]
mansion
yeah
I'd beat the [ __ ] out of her well he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] he's dead too
bad he didn't suffer more for you yeah
Zach says I forget his name but you guys
should do a show on that Argentine uh
killer who murdered like 200 something
kids yeah that was that one yeah I heard
about that one yeah somebody said his
name like later on you said it I don't
know if that Pedro Lopez 300 supposedly
says mr88 who knows if that's true
though I mean I could look it up I'm
just saying
that's a lot of little kids he was
living in like an Argentine Favela
molest and little little kids and killed
him boys I think mostly I mean if it was
like that's not crazy to think that
maybe an exaggeration because serial
killers will exaggerate how many they
killed we're talking about that we were
talking about that earlier
might have been a fraction of that it
might have been 40. you know which is
still a lot but I mean yeah that's still
40 too many clearly 400 300 I don't know
well let's do the math
well you know it's not crazy because if
it was over several years let's say
three let's say it was 300.
um I'm going Spock on the on the [ __ ] if
it was 300 I mean if he was killing
people over like a several year period
yeah I mean that's
that's really like not that's maybe one
a week or something like that which
that's not crazy that was [ __ ] would
[ __ ] pile up on yeah but people would
know
it depends on their situation depends on
the situation I don't know I have to
look it up like I said I don't know why
yeah we got to look more into that case
we should do that case
yeah well we should do that case let me
give me my pen from give me some my pen
a little more into that [ __ ] because
that was another one uh Camp guy said
look at baby farms in Victorian England
I've been wanting to well I need some
paper too I need something to write on
um I've been wanting to do a show about
something that has some space on it
there's a bunch of little pieces of
paper here I know
there's a little
I mean there's a [ __ ] ton of little
papers well there should be like a
little
thing that I can write on like right
right now no right now where are these
little papers coming from anywhere that
has space on it okay okay
so we're gonna talk about Pedro Lopez
and then the baby Farm thing I've been
wanting to do a show about
um
Amelia Dyer
for a long time who I think she was kind
of like one of the most famous ones that
did like the baby Farms well and like I
said I kind of feel like back in the
Victorian era
because people had children and a lot of
them died before they reached five years
old because of disease or whatever
because you know the conditions were not
great
um
I'm not saying people weren't as
attached to their children back then
but maybe I don't know maybe you had to
like kind of uh you had to cultivate
some kind of like distance from them
because it's like well I'm I had to die
I had this kid but it's like they
probably they might die so I don't want
to get too attached
it's like but I can have it I can have
another one it's like raising chickens
you that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying and I kind of and that's
shitty that's terrible that should never
happen I mean I kind of feel like I
believe that's the way it was well I
well I don't know I kind of feel like to
me depends on the family I guess it
depends on the family and it depends on
the person yeah because I kind of feel
like I mean if you have a kid
yeah you would think that I mean just
from you know an evolutionary standpoint
you you know you would be like oh I need
to protect this kid or like this is the
thing I don't I feel like it would be
harder to kind of have a just a coldness
toward it's like well this one's
probably gonna die so I'm not gonna get
too attached I'm gonna take care of it
and everything but I'm not gonna be too
upset
I don't know I kind of feel like that
maybe wasn't I you know people got upset
about it well you heard about like there
was there was anecdotal evidence back
then of like people that were you know
famous and stuff like that and they had
babies that died and looked like they
never got over it right
and it's like that makes more sense to
me because like even back then when life
was maybe cheaper and like maybe more
kids died in childhood
um but you would still I mean that's
still a person that's still a person
that you gave birth to I think I think
things depended upon how understandable
it was if it was natural causes then
they probably got her over it a lot
quicker but if it was just
disappearances you'd think they wouldn't
get over there what happened to that kid
and that's still like I think that still
applies nowadays because it's like and
you hear that from like families of
people whose uh because you know I've
written about some cases too where you
know somebody's child got kidnapped for
example and you assume they're probably
dead but it's because it's been 20 30
years but they don't know you know the
body's never been found it's like that
must be [ __ ] horrible that must be I
mean it's bad enough like you know yeah
your kid's dead they found the body but
it's like it must be worse never knowing
whether they're talking about Keys man
it must be worse never knowing talking
about keys and Lopez hardcore in the
comments section yeah I'll put that in
the in the poll for the next one and
we'll see how that goes
Mr 88 said Americans assume children
necessarily have an adult looking out
for them not so in some parts of the
world yeah and for sure yeah I mean
mostly the comments I was making mostly
applies to like the Western World you
know America Europe stuff like that
where you know most children if you see
them walking around loose obviously but
I'm gonna tell I'm gonna tell a story
when I was in Brazil just before I
joined the army
I was driving around I've been driving I
was riding around with a [ __ ] cab
driver who was a friend of mine and a
[ __ ] cute Brazilian two three cute
Brazilian girls I was I knew in the back
seat and went through a certain part of
Sao Paulo Brazil
and they had a bunch of little boys
running around in in a area that was
known for prostitution
and the girl the Brazilian girls in the
back
said wait a minute what the [ __ ] are
these are they pimping these little boys
out and there was a cop a Brazilian cop
standing on a standing near near the
corner there and they told the uh Jenny
valda who was the guy who's driving they
said let me talk to this cop they were
outraged
and they said they got all these little
boys out there are they pimping those
little boys out are they selling ass and
the cop says yeah they are and so why
don't you stop and he's like what the
[ __ ] am I going to do about this [ __ ]
they don't [ __ ] have any food
you know what I mean
and you know I mean how can I stop this
so that that was the weirdest thing that
I saw in South America right there
but it kind of made sense in the context
of Brazil it was already [ __ ] chaos
the cop was like what could I do to stop
this
you know it they gotta eat too
and there was just some weird [ __ ]
which is awful it's awful to anybody
especially a kid would have to like well
they weren't they were like
9 10 11 12. and they're out there
turning tricks and they didn't have
anybody with them they were out there
just doing it and he's like well what am
I what can I do about it
and even those Brazilian girls who were
teenagers at the time were appalled
today wasn't normal even for them yeah
you know that that's what they're trying
to say that's probably good it wasn't
normal it shouldn't be normal yeah
they're like this shouldn't be right
anywhere right I mean I know it happens
I'm just saying it shouldn't happen and
the cop the local cop from that area was
like what what can I do they gotta eat
you know
that was his response
yeah it's almost kind of like yeah
that's the thing it's like yeah you can
say about the capital like not doing
anything but it's like he probably
thought of it was like well these kids
don't have any parents and it's just
kind of like what are they going to do
if I crack down on it right now now I
lock them up then they go to jail where
it's even worse yeah that's what he's
thinking and then they're gonna get
abused there and then they won't and if
I stop them they're not gonna have any
money like right they're not gonna have
anything so that's something for
anything to eat that's how a [ __ ]
South American Brazil which like I said
that's that's [ __ ] horrific he didn't
agree with it but he's like what can I
do right you know I can't do anything
yeah because it'll just make it worse
for them
and
you know I guess I was about
17 18.
when that happens and it was in Sao
Paulo
I was dating one of them and then
[ __ ] around with the other one
they were friends I was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was a [ __ ] you know back I was dead
[ __ ] it's crazy
yeah but that's just the way it was I
liked them both though Tom reliving His
Glory Days it wasn't Glory Days it was
the Genesis it was the Genesis those
girls were both awesome though
see you just couldn't like pick between
them you so you had no I was with one of
them the other one kept [ __ ] making a
move trying to steal me and of course
you couldn't like let that I was [ __ ]
17.
of course not I was running them both
but they knew I think they knew they
didn't
sure justify it oh yeah
but uh no I'm [ __ ] and then General
the [ __ ] cab driver he was only
[ __ ] 15 years 10 15 years older than
me he's probably trying to scam on him
too
how did I find that [ __ ]
but uh yeah this [ __ ] was [ __ ] funny
but no when I saw that happen that that
kind of changed my outlook uh like he
over the over the years have you guys
listened into this program you probably
heard me say certain things about cops
even though grafters I went to high
school and he's a friend of mine
the cops and the [ __ ] legal system
growing up in South America or parsley
growing up partially in South America
kind of made me see how the futility of
[ __ ] law enforcement how it really is
when you actually get down to it people
do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and uh maybe that cop was right he was
like what the hell can I do what if I do
something about it it gets worse for
them
yeah well and the thing about it like
you said in a system like that like one
person is gonna feel like well anything
I do is probably gonna have negative
consequences just like you know it's
going to be a ripple effect right and I
don't want to be responsible for this
little kid like not having something to
eat or like being going to jail or
something like that so I get it I get it
right
um but the more people do that like the
more systemic the problem becomes also
well there's no system in Brazil That's
what I mean this [ __ ] yes the system
concept is a white people thing if you
ask me yeah [ __ ] the rest yeah I mean
it's [ __ ] chaos I mean the way when
we talk about things we're generally
talking about things from like a West
Western point of view like a U.S or
european like people you know we have
like a system in place for dealing with
kind of [ __ ] which is [ __ ] up but it's
still kind of works sometimes
um but you know what I mean but but I
understand that there are many many
parts of the world where it does not
where that doesn't happen yeah it's more
kind of like the Medieval Era right you
know yeah so I'm very aware of that I'm
very aware of that Mr uh 88 says Pedro
Lopez who we were talking about for uh
his upbringing and background is
horrifying and people would not know
about Pedro Lopez's victims like they
would in America because at the time
Colombia had a massive orphan and
homeless childhood population in the
tens of thousands that's kind of what I
was thinking much easier I think that's
kind of why if you look at the Wikipedia
page which I have yeah of uh serial
killers which with the largest number of
victims almost all of them will be
Central in South America yeah and I
think that's probably for that very
reason right it's the Medieval Era
basically is because there's
well there's more of us like I said a
lack of system in place where it's just
gonna like nowadays you know in most
parts of the US not everywhere I
understand but like most parts of the US
like you know punish you like yeah a kid
gets kidnapped you know they're gonna
jump on that yeah
um you know in Central South America
some parts of Central South America not
so much depending on where it is
depending on where it is yeah so yeah
it's not going to be the same yeah so
you're right bro and
Colombia was coming out of a [ __ ]
Civil War I think in the 60s or 70s it
was always [ __ ] up in Colombia so you
could probably get away with a lot of
[ __ ] if you're a criminal especially a
pedophile because they didn't have time
to catch you you know they just didn't
they had other fish to fry
and you have large what we call the
Brazil favelas which are
squatters [ __ ] camps everywhere
I mean it would [ __ ] make the the
United States version of the 1920s it
would make that [ __ ] blush you know
favelas were
illegal squatter camps almost illegal
squatter cities yeah I was gonna say
they were almost like cities they're
like City size and uh
yeah
cartels random yeah and what went on in
there was not yeah it was just so it
wasn't regulated so if it was happening
in there then yeah I can understand it
but I would still think eventually
somebody would come after you
because they also in those favelas they
had militias in there
you know they had and they also had
cartels in there
and you would think somebody would have
complained
a cartel would come after you whether or
not they could find you would be
something else but
how much I bet they knew that they were
looking for him
Mr Eddie it said uh Jenny and or Tom did
you receive my message about sending you
a movie uh I did not where'd you send it
where did you send it to
you yeah we got a bunch of uh okay porn
Bots porn Bots porn Bots are [ __ ] hey
hey man please ban the porn box Love
chat best adult dating site I kind of
doubt that but okay
Mr 88 said uh yeah Tom Columbia was just
coming out of a civil war has a massive
shortage of parents right okay yeah so
it looks like there's a lot of Orphans
and stuff like that friend of ours was
involved in that Civil War he actually
married a friend of ours that's right he
um who is this [ __ ] beautiful
Gothic his name is Jacob Angel you could
you'll be able to find him well that's
still his name is a skinny Colombian guy
big wings he looks like the devil with
wings and he was on a bunch of Colombian
television programs Jacob was awesome
uh their marriage didn't work out he
went back to Colombia but uh his brother
Jacob was a sniper in the Colombian Army
and his brother was some kind of an
officer
and his brother was constantly in and
out of some kind of trouble having to do
the massacre that happened
uh it was it was not this particular
time but a little bit after I think in
the 80s and the 90s I don't know exactly
what had happened
but um
yeah
Colombia was interrupt in a rough
situation although I don't [ __ ]
I don't blame anybody it was a very
confusing time in Colombia
said he sent it to you my email address
the Hotmail one okay well I'll check
after the show yeah I'll check out the
show and answer if I see it yeah
that should be there all right so are
you you seem like you're I'm loaded yeah
obviously are you ready
sure I want to make you something to eat
yeah what are you doing I'm hungry well
I'll get down there and make some I got
uh I got ramen
I got uh sandwiches
I got uh
uh I don't remember I got burritos Ramen
sounds good no it's Ramen okay making
some Ramen
put some eggs in there yeah we gotta
wait we got any eggs I think so okay
I'll sell but you gotta eggs put some
eggs in there what if I don't have eggs
ah if you don't have eggs then I guess a
sandwich will do okay all right but I
would rather have Ramen with it okay
uh Zach says are you guys into Leonard
Cohen I just got into his music
I love Leonard Cohen yeah yeah talk to
me about that [ __ ] yeah I'm super into
Leonard Cohen I've got like I don't have
all his albums but I have like a whole
bunch of them so I listen to them live
all the time so yeah get with me on that
all right so
what is it it's Wednesday okay so we'll
be back Friday night for our Side Tracks
show but we live stream after this too
we what we live stream also we're gonna
live stream tomorrow aren't we no oh we
don't tomorrow's Friday Friday is
Thursday okay tomorrow's Thursday we
take the day off we don't live stream on
Thursdays schedule well yeah I got to I
got a whole you don't understand I have
like a whole she knows I have like two
months worth of [ __ ] like laid out like
out of time I thought we did tomorrow
yeah tomorrow is Thursday okay Thursday
and Saturday the only days that we don't
last right but I still put up videos
those days okay but I don't we don't
laugh at all these days because I need
some time off okay so I can do other
[ __ ] I'm still working those days I'm
just not live streaming but yeah so
we'll be back Friday night for the
Sidetrack show so that should be fun
where we can drink and you can talk
about whatever you want to oh stop it we
did you know I don't have to have a
topic
although I did get through the [ __ ] at
least so that was something I tried to
keep it short I thought it was a good
show I try to keep it short I thought it
was a good ship but you know uh Zach
says also why not make a a
Ramen burrito sandwich no you can't do
it it'd be a little weird it'd be a
little with his word
honestly I'm a big fan of just like a
bowl of ramen with some boiled eggs I
could do it and some vegetables I'll do
it if we have that I got vegetables but
you know I got it all right okay well
yeah put some vegetables in there all
right all right so we will see you guys
Friday evening thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we'll see you guys later
bye